FOR TODAY WILL DISCUSS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAYBE VISION
PROPOSALS FOR VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM SCHOOL STARS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER --
ONE FUTURE WORK.
FUTURE WORK COMMISSION AND LET
AGENCY OPERATIONS
[inaudible]
JUST.
THE PROPOSAL.
HELLO MADAM SECRETARY HELLO.
I LIKE THE RING.
I'M SORRY LIKE THE RING TO THAT.
MATTER OF FACT.
LET OF SECRETARY. FOR THE
COMPLIMENT.
I DON'T THINK I'M NOT GOING
HEARINGS.
THIS CAN ONLY GET BETTER I SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY I
WANTED TO JUST TAKE A COUPLE
MINUTES -- TO BECAUSE THIS ITEM
IS ABOUT THE LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY VISION FOR
THE WORK -- THE DEPARTMENTS AND
DIVISIONS UNDER THE LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
TOUCH THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES ON A
DAILY BASIS. FOR THE LOWEST WAGE
EARNERS IN THE STATE WE ENFORCE
LABOR STANDARDS THAT PROTECT
EMPLOYEES FROM POVERTY.
INJURY RETALIATION. FOR THOSE
OUT OF A JOB WE PROVIDE
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DISABILITY
INSURANCE TO ELIGIBLE EMPLOYEES.
AND TRAINING AND SKILLS BUILDING.
FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES WE OVERSEE PUBLIC
SECTOR LABOR RELATIONS.
AND FOR THE ECONOMY AS A WHOLE
AND FOR THE EMPLOYERS.
WE PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FOR WORKER TRAINING.
WE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
AND WE CONNECT JOB SEEKERS TO
PROGRAMS APPRENTICESHIPS
AVAILABLE IMPROPER CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES AT EMPLOYERS WHO
UNDERSTAND THAT INVESTING IN
THEIR PEOPLE IS THE BEST
INVESTMENT THEY CAN MAKE IN
THEIR BUSINESS.
AND WE ALSO PROVIDE LABOR MARKET
DATA.
THAT WE USED TO MEASURE THE
IMPACT OF OUR POLICIES AND PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE.
SO BECAUSE OF THIS WIDE REACH
THE EXPERIENCE THAT THE PUBLIC
HAS INTERACTING WITH THE LABOR
AGENCY AT ALL OF OUR DEPARTMENTS
AND DIVISIONS.
CAN DRAMATICALLY SHAPE THEIR
VIEW OF GOVERNMENT.
AND SO IT IS THE ROLE OF THE
LABOR AGENCY AND MY JOB AS LABOR
SECRETARY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
LOOK AT OUR OPERATIONAL.
I'M FUNCTIONS THAT WE
STREAMLINED TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE CAN.
THAT WE ENGAGE IN PROACTIVE WORK
IN ORDER -- TO INSURE THAT WE'RE
DOING OUR JOBS WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
AND THAT OUR WORK IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE PARTIES BOTH OF THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE.
AND SO THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE PRIORITIES.
ONE OF THEM IS THE FUTURE OF
WORK COMMISSION.
ARE THERE ARE POSITIONS THAT
WOULD HELP TO STOP THE WORK OF
THE COMMISSION AND FUNDAMENTALLY
THAT WORK IS TO ENSURE THAT.
INNOVATION AND AUTOMATION ARE
NOT ON A COLLISION COURSE WITH
JOBS -- WORKPLACE STANDARDS AND
A STRONG ECONOMY THAT LIFTS UP
EVERY CALIFORNIA.
AND SO WHAT WE'LL BE DOING IS
LOOKING AT AT POLICIES ASSESSING
OF PREDICTIVE -- MEASURES OF
WHERE JOBS ARE GOING WHAT JOB
WILL BE IMPACTED WHAT JOBS WE
LOST AND WHAT WE CAN DO AS
GOVERNMENT TO HELP -- TO TO
INSURE THAT.
AS THE STATE OF INNOVATION AS A
STATE WORKPLACE JUSTICE WE ALIGN
OUR OUR OUR VALUES IN CREATING A
STRONG ECONOMY.
UP WE ARE A PART OF LOOK AT THE
OPERATIONAL FUNCTIONS IS ALSO A
WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
STREAMLINE TO MAKE MORE
EFFECTIVE OUR SERVICES TO
WORKERS WHO ARE SEEKING JOBS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT OUR WORK
FOR SERVICES ARE OF ARE ALIGNED
THERE'S A COHERENT STRATEGY AND
THAT -- THAT THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT A WAY TO PROVIDE OF A
STREAMLINED USER FRIENDLY METHOD
OF GETTING ACCESS TO WORK FOR
WORK WORKFORCE BENEFITS.
UP AND FINALLY OF OUR PROPOSAL
ALSO SEEKS -- TO PUT POSITIONS
IN THE LABOR AGENCY THAT WOULD
LEAD THESE EFFORTS THE STRATEGIC
PROACTIVE EFFORT -- TO TO TO
IMPROVE OUR SERVICES AND TO MAKE
THE BEST USE OF THE OF OF THE
RESOURCES THROUGHOUT THE LABOR
AGENCY.
I I I CAN SEE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT BUT I'M GONNA STOP
HERE AND SEE IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FINANCE [inaudible]
LL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAS ALAMO THE LA
L. -- AS A SECRETARY TO MENTION
THIS PROPOSAL IS IS SORT OF UP
TO TWO PIECES ONE RELATED TO THE
AGENCY STAFF POSITIONS IN THE
OTHER RELATED TO THE THE
COMMISSION ON THE FUTURE OF WORK.
OUT REGARDING THE LATTER ON THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL
INCLUDED A A SIMILAR IDEA.
AT THE TIME CALLED THE THE WORK
GROUP ON THE FUTURE OF WORK AS
PART OF ACTUALLY -- ITEM FIVE OF
THIS AGENDA THE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDED WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AT THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
ON WHEN WE ORIGINALLY RECEIVED
THE THE MAY REVISION WE WERE
UNDER THE ASSUMPTION THAT THESE.
TWO ARE SIMILARLY NAMED
COMMISSIONS WERE SORT OF EXISTED
AT THE SAME TIME AND WE FOLLOWED
UP WITH WITH -- AGENCY STAFF AND
CLARIFIED THAT THE WORK GROUPS
OF THE JANUARY VERSION HAS
EVOLVED INTO THIS PROPOSAL ON
THAT'S OUR CURRENT UNDERSTANDING
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH A TO
Z. TO BETTER UNDERSTAND.
THAT DYNAMIC IN THAT PROCESS AND
CLARIFY FOR YOU AND YOUR STAFF
BUT OTHERWISE -- REGARDING THAT
THE NATURE OF THE COMMISSION OR
THE AGENCY PROPOSAL WITH NO
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SURE ANY
QUESTIONS.
FIRST I WANT TO JOIN THE CHAIR
AND WELCOMING MADAM SECRETARY
AND AGREE THAT IT DOES HAVE A
NICE RING TO IT -- HAD A COUPLE
OF JUST DAY QUESTIONS AROUND
SOME SPECIFIC ISSUES AND
WONDERING IF YOU MIGHT BE
COVERING THROUGH THE COMMISSION --
NUMBER OF US HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BEEN VERY INTERESTED
IN THE TOPIC OF PORTABLE
BENEFITS -- I ALSO COUPLE YEARS
AGO HAD A BILL TRYING TO THINK
THROUGH -- FAIR SCHEDULING
POLICIES IN THE WORK FORCE GIVEN
AUTOMATION AND TECHNOLOGY AND
I'M ALSO CURIOUS ABOUT HOW YOUR
THING ABOUT AROUND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT I'M ASSUMING THESE
ARE TOPICS THAT YOU MAY BE
COVERING BUT COULD USE IS GIVE
US A SENSE OF THE THE WORK OF
THE COMMISSION ARE YOU GONNA.
LOOK AT SPECIFIC TOPICS LIKE
THIS.
TELL US WHAT WHAT THE COMMISSION
GONNA DO THANK YOU SO MUCH SO OF
THE BROADER ANSWER IS YES THOSE
ARE -- THOSE AND OTHER ISSUES ON
THE TABLE -- PART OF THE CHARGE
OF THE COMMISSION IS TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT.
WHAT IS THE NATURE OF WORK HOW
WAS WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE AND
WHAT KIND OF SOCIAL COMPACT DO
WE WANT IN CALIFORNIA? TO INSURE
THAT EVERYBODY SHARES IN THE
PROSPERITY OF THE STATE -- AS
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER NOTED THERE
IS A HUGE GAP BETWEEN THE RICH
AND THE POOR THERE'S A PROBLEM
OF AFFORDABILITY AND THIS WILL
RELATE TO MY COLLEAGUE -- CHAZ'S
POINT ABOUT THE FUTURE OF WORK
WHICH IS THAT MORE MANY OF THE
BROAD POLICY -- IDEAS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION UP.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO CREATE A
GOOD JOBS THAT IN THE COMMUNITY
THE MOST AND SO -- ADDRESSING
CLIMATE ADDRESSING THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE ADDRESSING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TRANSPORTATION AND CLEAN WATER
ACCESS ALL OF THESE ARE NOT
POLICIES THAT EXIST IN A VACUUM
THEY ARE OF EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS.
AND ENSURE MORE EQUITY AND A BIG
PART OF THAT IS WHAT WILL THE
JOBS THAT ARE GENERATED FROM
THOSE -- THOSE EFFORTS LOOK LIKE
AND THAT IS WITHIN THE VERY
DEFINITION OF THE FUTURE OF WORK
UP SO THE IDEA OF WHAT THE
PORTABLE BENEFITS RIGHT THE IDEA --
OF OF OF SCHEDULING AND
WORKPLACE FLEXIBILITY ALL OF
THOSE ARE WITH IN THE REALM OF
FUTURE OF WORK AND OUR GOAL IS
TO BRING TOGETHER.
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERTS PEOPLE
REPRESENT EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES
TECH COMPANIES INNOVATORS
DISRUPTORS VENTURE CAPITALISTS
ACADEMICS AND RESEARCHERS TO
TACKLE ALL OF THESE UP ALL OF
THESE ISSUES.
RIGHT WHAT CM DO A TIME FRAME
FOR WHEN THE REPORT MIGHT BE
FINISHED SO THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
OF INCLUDES A FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY PROGRESS REPORT -- I
BELIEVE THAT THE WORK OF THE
COMMISSION WILL CONTINUE BEYOND
THAT AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
PLANNING FOR AT LEAST ABOUT A
YEAR -- OF OF OF WORK AND THEN
ANOTHER YEAR OF TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE GONNA ROLL OUT --
AND ENGAGE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON
THE WORK OF THE COMMISSION AND
THEN ONE OTHER SUBSTANTIVE --
AREA -- YOU MENTIONED INCOME
INEQUALITY AND I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT TECHNOLOGY IS
CONCENTRATING WEALTH AND MAKING
INCOME INEQUALITY FORMER
EXACERBATED ARE YOU GONNA THINK
ABOUT TAX POLICIES OR OTHER.
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT FOR THE
ECONOMY THAT COME OUT OF THE
FACT THAT THE WORK FORCE HAS
CHANGED.
SO RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE MANY POSSIBILITIES AS
TO WHAT THE WHAT THE POLICIES OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WILL COME
FROM THE COMMISSION ARE AT
ADDRESSING THAT FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION OF OF POVERTY JOB
QUALITY AND HOW INNOVATION
AUTOMATION TECHNOLOGY CAN
ACTUALLY IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
NOT.
JUST WORKERS BUT ALL PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA IS A KEY PART OF THAT
SO WE'RE GONNA BE OPEN -- TO TO
ALL IT TOOK TO LOOK ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT THAT ARE GENERATED
BY THE CONVERSATION BY THE
COMMISSION MEMBERS.
AND ALSO LOOK FOR TO ENGAGING
WITH YOU ALL AS OF LEGISLATORS
ON ON ON ON WHAT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE AND WHAT
THEY COULD LOOK LIKE GREAT
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
PARTICULAR REPRESENTING A CITY
THAT.
REPRESENTS THAT TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION BUT ALSO VERY MUCH AS
STOOD WITH WORKERS WE SORT OF
REPRESENT THAT DICHOTOMY --
THESE ARE ALL ISSUES THAT WE ARE
GRAPPLING WITH AND LOOK FOR TO
YOU THOMAS THE ANSWERS.
Q. SEVEN THANK YOU JUST IRVINE
AUTOMATION PART A LITTLE BIT --
OBVIOUSLY AUTOMATION OF A LOT AG
IN MY DISTRICTS LOSING MORE MORE
AUTOMATION'S BECAUSE THE COST OF
LABOR.
AND AND HOW DEEP YOU CAN GO INTO
THAT BESIDES LABOR PART BECAUSE
SOME OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH --
SOME LOST CLIMATE CHANGE -- WE
DO A LOT IN CALIFORNIA HERE.
THAT.
IS NOT DONE ELSEWHERE SO YOU
LOOK AT OUR FOLKS ARE INVOLVED
IN THE AG INDUSTRY.
OTHER FEES ARE A LOT MORE HIGHER
NOT BECAUSE OF LABOR BECAUSE
WHETHER IT'S IT'S PESTICIDES OR
FARM EQUIPMENT IMPLEMENTS SO HOW
HOW DEEPLY GO TO THE AUTOMATION
PIECE.
SO MY HOPE IS -- AND THE PLAN IS
TO ACTUALLY GO DEEPLY A KNIFE TO
COME UP WITH MEANINGFUL
PROPOSALS THAT THEN WE ARE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY TURN INTO REALITY
IMPLEMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OF THE THESE THESE ARE NOT NEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR NOT
QUESTIONS THAT WERE ONLY ASKING
CALIFORNIA BUT I DO THINK THAT
BECAUSE OF THE SIZE OF OUR STATE.
BECAUSE OF THE TALENT POOL
BECAUSE OF THE INVESTMENT OF
EMPLOYERS.
WHO ARE BOTH OF THE CUTTING EDGE
OF TECHNOLOGY AND IT AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THE -- STRONG
WORKPLACE STANDARDS ARE GOOD FOR
BUSINESS BECAUSE OF ALL THOSE
THINGS I THINK THAT WE HAVE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY ASK
CALIFORNIA TO REALLY DIVE IN
MORE DEEPLY AND NOT JUST QUIT
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE CAN TALK
ABOUT BUT THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
DEMONSTRATE HOW THEY REALLY WORK.
SO I I AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT
BUTFOR INSTANCE IFFOR FOR
FRUIT AND CITRUS IT'S A
WORLDWIDE MARKET WOULD DEAL WITH
A LOT OF CITRUS CONFIRMATION.
OBVIOUSLY THE COST OF OF DOING
BUSINESS IN ASIA IS MUCH CHEAPER.
NOT JUST LABOR I'M TALKING ABOUT
EVERYTHING ELSE THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS OF A I MEAN JUST TO
REALLY GET A TO DO A DEEP DIVE
ON THAT AND REALLY LOOK AT THAT
AND THE SAME THING WITH
STRAWBERRIES WE SEE A LOT OF
STRAWBERRIES.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH ARE
PRESENT PLUS DRIVERS GOING HERE
BUT ALSO A LOT GOING TO MEXICO
SO THAT THE COSTS ARE MUCH
DIFFERENT BUT YET.
IT'S IT'S STILL WE'RE STILL
DOING THE SAME ANIMAL SO I MEAN
I WOULD HOPE THAT DIE WOULD BE
VERY DEEP AND REALLY BECAUSE NO
ONE YET HAS YET REALLY EXPORTED.
AND WHAT THE TRUE IMPACT ISSUES
ARE.
SO THE ANSWER IS YES WE WANT
EXPLORE THOSE AND THAT INDUSTRY --
IN PARTICULAR IS ONE THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT AS OF WILL SITTING
AT THE CROSSROADS OF MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT THAT YOU ASKED
ABOUT IN THAT THAT ARE DISCUSSED
IN OUR PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA PAUSE
BECAUSE WE HAVE MISTER LACKEY
HERE'S WITH A QUORUM SO CAN WE
HAVE -- ROLL CALL PLEASE TO
STEPS QUORUM.
COOPER HERE. TO HEAR LACKEY.
THE VARIANCE IN WHAT.
SO WE THIRTY NINE THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR AS THEIR EMOTION.
A SECOND OUT -- ROLL CALL PLEASE.
FOR THE THIS IS FOR THE VOTE
EARLY CALENDAR -- ITEMS -- ONE
THROUGH [inaudible]
THIRTEEN YEAH.
I NEED TO HAVE -- SEPARATION
[inaudible]
IS NOT.
OKAY SO WHAT WHICH NUMBERS
[inaudible]
CAN -- SEE NUMBER [inaudible] TO
SEVEN AT TWO TEN TWELVE THIRTEEN
CHARGE. TO TEN TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN NOT SEVEN CORRECT
[inaudible]
OKAY SO.
THE FIRST TRUCK DRIVERS AND WE
ARE.
WITH EXCEPTION OF TWO TEN TWELVE
AND THIRTEEN OKAY IN A SECOND
OKAY A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY ACT AS AARON WICKS
[inaudible]
AND NOW.
IN ALL SECOND.
I'LL SECOND THAT.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY JUST SO I'M MORE THIS
IS TWO AND TEN COMBINE. TWO TEN
TO TWELVE OR THIRTEEN TELL YOU
WHAT OKAY. TO TO ATTEND NO.
OKAY.
ARE YOU WILL MODIFY THAT.
I'M MY OWN TO INTERNAL AND MAKE.
YOU MODIFIED YOUR MOTION TO TO
ATTEND.
OKAY.
YOU WANTED PHONE THIRTEEN
SEPARATELY THEN.
PLEASE OKAY -- SO FOR ITEM
NUMBER -- ISSUE NUMBER.
TWELVE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
WELL THE MOTION [inaudible]
ALSO GONNA. TWELVE COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY VOTING [inaudible]
NAZARIAN WICKS.
OKAY IN WE WERE MOTION -- FOR
THIRTEEN A SECOND THAT.
UBER HI [inaudible]
TO LACKEY [inaudible]
NOT VOTING.
THE VARIANT WICKS.
THE END SO I DO HAVE A COUPLE
MORE QUESTIONS BUT WILL THE
FUTURE OF THE WORK COMMISSION
REPORT BE COMPLETED.
THERE'S AN INTRAPARTY THAT WILL
BE COMPLETED IN FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY THAT'S OKAY THAT'S BUT
THAT WE HAVE NOT INDICATED WHEN
A FINAL REPORT WILL COME OUT OR
WERE POTENTIALLY INTERIM
INFORMATION -- AS WERE WORKING
OUT WILL COME OUT BUT I DO WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THE COMMISSION
ITSELF IS A PUBLIC BODY SO WE DO
ENCOURAGE.
PARTICIPATION INVOLVEMENT -- AND
ATTENDANCE BY ALL.
INCLUDE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AND MOVE THE PROPOSED FUTURE OF
WORK COMMISSION ALSO EVALUATE
THE IMPACT OF THE STATE'S
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS ON THE WORK
FORCE [inaudible]
BROADLY -- YES IN IN THE SENSE
THAT -- WHAT I MENTIONED EARLIER
RIGHT THAT THAT ARE THAT ARE
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS OUR
COMMITMENT -- TO POLICIES DO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR JOBS
THE NEED TO TRAIN WORKERS FOR
THOSE JOBS AS THE CHANGE AND
THOSE ARE ALL ABSOLUTELY
SQUARELY WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF
THE COMMISSION.
AND WHERE THE SIX ONGOING
POSITIONS NEEDED FOR THE LABOR
AGENCY.
SO THAT RELATES TO THE THE AT
THE FUTURE OF WORK -- COMMISSION
IS ONE ASPECT OF THE PROPOSAL
THE SECOND IS TO PROVIDE THE
STAFFING AND THE LEADERSHIP.
YET THE LABOR AGENCY TO FULFILL
THE ORIGINAL GOAL OF THE LABOR
AGENCY WHICH IS TO PROVIDE --
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVELOP A
COHERENT STRATEGY ACROSS ALL THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE DIVISIONS OF
THE BOARDS OF THE PANELS UNDER
THE LABOR AGENCY.
THANK YOU SOMEONE THINKING THAT
VICTORY FOR COMMITTEE HEARING
AND SPEAKING TO US -- REFER THE
CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL AND TAKE
ACTION NEXT WEEK SOARING HOME
THIS ITEM OPEN THANKS VERY MUCH
I WILL CHAIR THANK YOU ABSOLUTE
MEMBERS.
THIS REMOVED ITEM NUMBER -- TWO
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT.
YEAH I SEE THAT MISS WHICH HAS
JOINED US
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GREG EDWARDS I'M CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL NATIONS.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL -- GENTLY
EXPAND THE UNIT THAT WAS CREATED
IN THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN -- TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO REVIEW -- APART THE
CLAIMS -- TO INSURE THAT -- THIS
ACTIVITY WHICH WAS ESSENTIALLY
PRIOR TO THAT TIME.
NOT MONITORED NOT REVIEW THESE
ACTIONS ARE PRIVATE ACTIONS THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE EMPOWERED BY THE
AT TO TO TAKE IN LIEU OF THE
STATE.
AND SO IT WAS AGENCIES -- AND
THE DEPARTMENT'S DESIRE TO JUST --
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS MAKE SURE
THAT THE STATE'S -- INTERESTS
WERE WELL SERVED BY THIS PUZZLE
THIS PROPOSAL WILL.
ADD NINE POSITIONS AND ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS -- TO
EXPAND THIS EFFORT AND MY
COLLEAGUE WILL -- BRIEFLY KIND
OF PROVIDE A BROAD OVERVIEW OF
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL WILL
SPECIFICALLY IN COPLEY
ACCOMPLISH AND WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU ON THE PARKING UNIT
WAS STARTED A FEW YEARS AGO WITH
THE IDEA OF PROVIDING SOME STATE
OVERSIGHT TO THE PAGO PROCESS TO
GET SOME IDEAS OF WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH IT.
AND TO PROVIDE SOME OF OVER A
FEW OF WHETHER IF THE SYSTEM WAS
BEING ABUSED OR NOT.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS OR WE HAVE
ON DONE THAT WE HAVE DONE THREE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF THINGS ONE
THING IS THAT WE REVIEW PAGA
NOTICES.
THAT COME BEFORE ALL OF THE OLD
W. T. H. O. TO REVIEW THEM TO
SEE TO GET AN IDEA OF WHAT IS
GOING ON ON THE SECOND THING
THAT WE DO IS SOME OF THE A
SUBSET OF THOSE CASES.
BASED UPON OF THE LIMITATIONS OF
OUR STAFFING AND THE PRIORITIES
THAT WE GIVE TO CERTAIN TYPE OF
CASES WE TAKE ON FOR
INVESTIGATION.
AS OPPOSED TO ALLOWING THOSE
CASES TO GROUP BE PURSUED BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THROUGH THE BY
THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S.
AND THEN THERE IS A THIRD OF A
CATEGORY OF WORK THAT WE DO
WHICH IS THAT WE REVIEW PROPOSED
SETTLEMENTS.
AND ALL OF THE PROPOSED
SETTLEMENTS ARE WHERE PRIVATE.
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S HAVE FILED
ACTIONS IN SUPERIOR COURT.
AND THOSE CASES ARE NOW BEFORE
THE COURT FOR SETTLEMENT
AUTHORIZATION WHICH IS REQUIRED
BY THE ACT.
IN THOSE SITUATIONS OR WE LOOK
AT THOSE TO GET SOME IDEA OF
WHETHER ONE THE PENALTIES ARE
BEING PAID TO THE STATE UNDER
THE AGREEMENT -- APPEAR TO BE.
ALL SUFFICIENT AND SECONDLY ALL
WHETHER THE WORKERS WHO WERE
AFFECTED BY THE VIOLATIONS ARE
BEING APPROPRIATELY COMPENSATED.
ON END IN THAT OTHER SAUCE.
OF POLICIES ARE ARE BEING
ENFORCED BECAUSE AFTER ALL THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S WHEN
THEY PURSUE THESE MATTERS IN
COURT ART AFFECT STEPPING INTO
THE SHOES OF THE STATE.
AND SO ALL THE UNIT WAS SET FOR
TWO LAW TO TO MONITOR THOSE
THINGS AND AND TO FIND OUT WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN TO PURSUE
CERTAIN CASES.
OF GRIEF WE THINK THAT THE UNIT
HAS BEEN SIX THIS WILL IN DOING
THAT -- THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
LARGE CASES OR WHICH THE UNIT
PICKED UP OFF FOR INVESTIGATION
AND HAS PER AND IS PURSUED ALL
OF THOSE CASES ON THEIR VARIETY
OF REASONS WHY.
ARE WE THINK THAT THE STATE
INTERVENTION IN THOSE CASES HAS
BEEN ALL IMPORTANT. TO THE
OVERALL ENFORCEMENT.
ON THERE SOME THINGS THAT WEEK
IS A STATE AGENCY ARE ABLE -- TO
TO TO ENFORCE THE LAW WHICH
PRIVATE PARTIES ARE NOT ABLE TO
DO SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK IS REALLY NOTABLE.
IS THAT THERE ARE CASES WHERE
THE SITUATIONS WITH VERY SEVERE
VIOLATIONS WHERE WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE THE STEP OF
COORDINATING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN ACTUALLY
GETTING PROSECUTION OF THOSE
CASES.
AND WE HAVE ONE OF THOSE CASES
ALL THAT'S ALREADY GONE THROUGH
WHERE THEY'RE AWFULLY PLEA
BARGAIN WAS ENTERED BY THOSE ALL
IN ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO BECAUSE
THOSE VIOLATIONS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE PURSUING
THE ECONOMIC OF RESTITUTION FOR
THE WORKERS MATTER FACT IN THAT
PARTICULAR CASE THAT I'M
REFERRING TO IS GOING FORWARD
TODAY ONE OF THE ATTORNEYS FOR
THE UNIT IS DOING THAT.
ON BUT WHAT IT'S BECOME CLEAR
OVER THE LAST.
YOUR OR TWO IS THAT THE AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE TO
THIS IS.
ALL COMMITTED TO THIS IS
INSUFFICIENT TO HAVING A
REASONABLE SAMPLE AT A
REASONABLE INPUT INTO THE SYSTEM
OVERALL.
AND IT'S THOUGHT THAT ON BY
ESSENTIALLY DOUBLING THE SIZE OF
THAT UNIT WE CAN EXTEND THE
SUCCESSES THAT THE UNIT IS HAD
THOSE FOR ALL TO TWO MORE TO
MORE SITUATIONS AND CONTINUE. TO
GET A BETTER HANDLE ON THE
SITUATION SUCH THAT THE ALL LAWS
ARE BEING ENFORCED IN THE
WORKERS OF WHO RELY ON US IN
THOSE LAWS.
ARE HAVING ARE GETTING REMEDIES
AND GETTING RESTITUTION FOR THE
WAGES THAT ARE OWED.
UNDER THIS WE WOULD BE ADDING ON
A COUPLE OF ATTORNEYS TO THE
UNIT.
ALSO OF THERE WOULD BE ON
INCREASES IN THE NUMBER OF
INVESTIGATORS -- IN THE THE HOPE
IS THAT WHILE WE WOULD ACTUALLY
BE DOING FEW WERE REFUSE OF
INCOMING PAGA NOTICES THAT THE
REVIEW THAT THE WORK THAT WE
WOULD BE DOING ON THOSE WOULD BE
MARCH MORE THOROUGH.
AND WHAT WE FOUND IN OUR FIRST
FEW YEARS SO THAT'S BEEN
THOROUGH UP TILL NOW.
NO IT'S BEEN WELL IT'S IT'S BEEN
THOROUGH FOR THE ONES THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN ON AND SO ON WITH THE
RESULT THERE THERE ARE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF REVIEWS -- THAT WE DO --
SO IN THE FIRST INSTANCE WHEN WE
GET WE AND WE GET ABOUT
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED NEW
PAGA CLAIMS BEING FILED EACH
MONTH WITH THE LW DA -- IN WILL
BE TO AS WE WE DO PROVIDE OF
APPLY SOME ANALYTICS TO THAT
TRYING TO FOCUS IN ON PRIORITY
AREAS.
SO NO FOR THE STATE FOR THE L.
W. D. A. AND THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ON THE PRIORITY IS
TO LOOK AT INDUSTRIES WHERE LOW
WAGE WORKERS HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
OF TO A LARGE EXTENT.
THERE ARE MANY OTHER BLOG PAGA
NOTICES TO COME IN FOR OTHER
INDUSTRIES FOR EXAMPLE FINANCIAL
SERVICES WITH RELATIVELY HIGH
PAID INDIVIDUALS INSURANCE
INDUSTRY THINGS LIKE THAT.
IN THOSE INSTANCES IN OF THOSE
CASES ARE BEING HANDLED
CURRENTLY BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND ON THEY CAN DOG DO THAT.
SUFFICIENTLY ON WHEN IT COMES TO
THE ISSUE OF THE LOW WAGE
INDUSTRIES ON YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHERE WE SEE ON THE MOST ABUSE
AND AND AND ONE OF FOCUS THE THE
ATTENTION.
WELL I AGREE WE NEED PREPARERS
BUT IT'S TRUE THAT MOST OF THE
MONEY GOES TO THE ATTORNEYS
THESE CASES AND NOT THE WORKERS.
WELL THAT.
THAT GETS TO THIS THIS ONE OF
THE OTHER AREAS WHICH IS OUR
REVIEW OF THE SETTLEMENT SO IT
IS THAT IS THAT CORRECT THE ALL
THAT'S THE I I YOU KNOW WE WE
DON'T HAVE.
ALL THAT JUST FOR ANECDOTALLY IT
APPEARS TO BE CORRECT IT IF IT
APPEARS THAT IN MANY INSTANCES
ON THE AMOUNT OF THE FEES.
OUR OUR YOU KNOW PROPORTIONATELY
OUTSIZED SO FOR OUT TO PROTECT
THE WORKERS SHOULD IN THE
MAJORITY OF THE MONEY THAT IS
COLLECTED GO THE WORKERS AND NOT
THE ATTORNEYS.
OLD ABSOLUTELY.
OKAY ABSOLUTELY HOW WE GO ABOUT
FIXING THAT.
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE ARE REVIEWING THOSE AND
WHAT.
AND WHAT WE HOPE TO DO WITH WITH
PART OF THE ADDITIONAL STAFFING.
IS TO BE INTERVENING IN COURT.
TO LOG COMMENT EDWARD
APPROPRIATE CHALLENGE ALL
PROPOSED SETTLEMENTS IS BEING
YOU KNOW OUT OF WHACK IN DOG IT
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD.
SEE OURSELVES DOING OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
IN THE FIRST FEW YEARS OF THE OF
THE PROGRAM THERE'S BEEN A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF ON ENGAGEMENT
WITH WOMEN -- REVIEWING THAT THE
PROPOSED SETTLEMENT BUT THERE
HAVE BEEN A LIMITED NUMBER OF
CASES WHICH WERE WHERE WE'VE
ACTUALLY INTERVENED.
ON TO COMMENT IN DAHLE PURSUE
THAT WE WOULD SEE THAT UNDER THE
PROPOSAL.
BEING LARGELY INCREASED SO THAT
WE WOULD BE COMMENTING ON
APPROXIMATELY SIX CASES A YEAR
IN COURT TRYING TO HAVE AN
IMPACT THAT WAY. ONE
LEGISLATURE'S ALWAYS BEEN. FOR
THE WORKERS IN SOME LAWS BE
PASSED MATURE LAWS. TO ENSURE
WORKERS RIGHT SO.
I DON'T SEE IT ANYWHERE IN THIS
REPORT.
AS FAR AS TRYING TO ADJUST THAT%
TO MAKE SURE THOSE FUNDS GO THE
WORKERS SO.
IT BE GOOD TO SEE THAT AT SOME
POINT REALLY IDENTIFIES THAT IS
BEING IS A PROBLEM BECAUSE IN
REVIEWING CASES WITH STAFF I
MEAN IT'S IT'S GLARINGLY --
RELEVANT THAT AND NOT RELEVANT
BUT IT'S IT'S JUST CLEARLY THAT --
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEES THE ONES THAT
ARE COMING ON THE SHORT END OF
THE STICK YOUR SITE WILL CITIES
IN TERMS OF THE WORK THAT WE DO.
RIGHT FOR EXAMPLE WE JUST HAD A
CASE IN SAN JOSE WITH RESTAURANT
WORKERS.
WARES SOMEHOW THIS EMPLOYER.
DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
HOURS PASSED THE THE DAY OR
FORTY AND WE NEEDED TO BE PAID A
TIME AND A HALF WE PICKED UP
THAT CASE BECAUSE WE SAW WAS FOR
LOW WAGE WORKERS WE WORKED THE
CASE UP WE ENDED UP GETTING A
RESOLUTION.
OF ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ON THAT CASE WHICH MORE THAN --
COMPENSATED THE WORKER FOR THE
WORKERS FOR THE UNPAID WAGES.
AND WHAT WE RECEIVED FOR THE
STATE ON THAT CASE WAS ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
CIVIL PENALTIES.
NO WE THINK THE OBVIOUSLY OUR
FIRST GOAL IN THE WORK THAT WE
DO.
IS TO GET THE MONEY INTO THE
POCKETS OF THE WORKERS -- IN SO
THAT'S WHAT WE DO OF WE WE WE TO
THOROUGH INVESTIGATIONS IN THEM
WE WE LITIGATE THE CASES IF NEED
BE TO GET THAT RESULTS SO BY
BEING AGGRESSIVE WITH THAT WE
THINK WE ARE ACCOMPLISHING.
THE END THAT THE THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
TRANSFERRING THAT SAME -- SAME
PRIORITIES TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR
THAT'S THAT IT'S GONNA TAKE
CONCERTED WORK OVER THE NEXT
YEARS IN PART OF IT IS BY
EXAMPLE AND PART OF IT IS GONNA
BE BY US BEING IN THE SUPERIOR
COURT.
AND REALLY YOU KNOW SAYING.
GIVING OUR OPINION AS TO
SETTLEMENTS THAT ARE DEFICIENT
THAT NEED TO BE RE WORKING THEY
NEED TO GO BACK AND DO MORE WORK
ON IT AND AND GET THE WORKERS
WHAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FINANCE.
HI MARC MINUTES APART AND
FINANCE JUST WANTED -- TO IF YOU
KNOW EMPHASIZE THAT WE HAVE
MUTUAL GOALS -- AWAY THIS
PROPOSAL INTENDS TO DO IS --
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO TAKE ON
MORE CASES AND WHICH WOULD LEAD
TO MORE FORSMAN OF LABOR LAWS
AND THE BETTER RECOVERY WAGES
FOR AFFECTED OF AFFECTED
AFFECTED EMPLOYEES [inaudible]
LL.
THANK YOU I'M WITH REGARD TO
THIS SPECIFIC BUDGET PROPOSAL
IT'S A AT SOAP WORKLOAD
AUGMENTATION -- WE'VE REVIEWED
IT OBVIOUSLY THAT THE POCKET
UNIT HAS HAD SOME FRUITFUL
INVESTIGATIONS SENSE IN THE IN
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND WE
SUSPECT THAT THAT WOULD CONTINUE
TO BE THE CASE WITH THE
AUGMENTATIONS.
OF COMMENTS SPECIFIC TO THAT
ELEMENT ON YOUR COMMENTS THOUGH
MISTER CHAIR I THINK DO RAISE
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE THE
POLICY AROUND PAGA -- POLICY
CHANGES WERE ENACTED SEVERAL
YEARS AGO ON THIS PART OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS.
TO PROVIDE THE AGENCY MORE
OVERSIGHT OVER THESE PRIVATE
LEGAL ACTIONS ON ONE BY PRODUCT
OR BENEFIT OF THIS AUGMENTATION
MIGHT BE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
OUR OFFICE AS WELL AS A LABOR
AGENCY.
LEARNS MORE ABOUT THE LANDSCAPE
ON THE THE PRIVATE LEGAL SIDE SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
WEATHERED CHANGES OR ADJUSTMENTS
TO ITS OVERSIGHT ROLE ON ARE
APPROPRIATE FUTURE CHAIR THE
CHAIRS COMMITTEE HAVE A STRONG
INTEREST IN THAT AND SEEING THAT
GOING FORWARD SO.
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH THE TWO
OF YOU ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
THANK.
A QUESTION COMMITTEE.
I WENT UP A PUBLIC COMING ON
THIS ITEM [inaudible]
NOTION SPEAK.
JUST ONE MORE QUESTION WHAT IS A
MAYBE VISION PROPOSED SHIFTING
OVERSIGHT FROM PAGA UNIT TO THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN PROPOSAL
ESTABLISHED -- A POSITION IN THE
LABOR I MEAN SORRY IN THE LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY --
TO PROVIDE A GENERAL OVERSIGHT
AND POLICY DIRECTION THAT
POSITION REMAINS THAT HAS NOT
CHANGED WHAT WE ARE STREAMLINING.
THIS PROPOSAL IS THE DAY TO DAY
OVERSIGHT IN MANAGEMENT OF THE
STAFF AFFECTED LEE ENGAGED IN
THE NOTICE REVIEW IN THE
INVESTIGATION IN THE SETTLEMENT
REVIEW SO AGENCY OVERSIGHT
REMAINS.
OF THE HOPE IS THAT IS THAT THIS
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE WILL HELP
US STREAMLINED THE DAY TO DAY
MANAGEMENT OF THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU ISRAEL THIS ITEM OPEN --
SOLANO NEXT AUTUMN.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE GENERAL
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
INTENDED TO HARMONIZE -- TWO
SEPARATE PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
THAT WILL PASS A. B. -- NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WAS PASSED IN --
TWENTY SIXTEEN IN A. B. -- I'M
SORRY SB -- THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
WAS PASSED A TWO YEARS LATER IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF THOSE
SEPARATE PIECES OF LEVEL THE
LEGISLATION BOTH REQUIRE
REPORTING FROM THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY -- V. REPORTING
REQUIRED WAS SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
UNDER EACH OF BILL AND SO THIS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
INTENDED TO HARMONIZE THOSE
DIFFERENCES STREAMLINED THAT
REPORTING -- AND ACCOMPLISH THE
THE NATIONAL -- INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE -- AND THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU SORT OF STOPPER SECOND
BECAUSE WE HAVE -- MISTER THERE
IN THIS WEEK'S HERE MARIN GO FOR
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
THOUGH BOTTLING CALENDAR -- ALL
THE ONLY ISSUES EXCEPT TO TEN
TWELVE AND THIRTEEN THE SYRIAN
[inaudible]
WICKS HI.
NUMBER ONLY ISSUES TO AND TEN MS
ARIENS [inaudible]
WICKS.
FIVE THE ONLY ISSUE TWELVE
NAZARIAN.
WICKS.
FIVE AND THE ONLY ISSUE THIRTEEN
NAZARIAN.
AND WICKS HI [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
LL.
NO COMMENTS ON THIS POST ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IF COMMISSION THE PUBLIC.
OKAY -- GOING CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL THIS ITEM OPEN -- I
SHOULD NEVER FOR EMPLOYMENT
BUILDING APARTMENT MAYBE VISION
PROPOSALS
.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO SEVEN MEMBERS --
PATRON WITH EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT -- WITH
SEVERAL ITEMS IN FRONT OF YOU
THE CLAIMANTS PRIVACY MEASURE
WHICH IS AN EXACT WHICH IS THE
RESULT OF THESE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S.
REVIEW OF OUR DOCUMENTS AND
TRYING TO IMPROVE OUR SYSTEMS.
BENEFITS SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION
WAS A CONTINUATION.
OF A PROJECT TO HELP MODERNIZE
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE.
A BENEFITS IN THE WAY THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ARE ACCUSTOMED.
TO INTERACTING WITH -- NOT ONLY
STATE AGENCIES BUT ALSO -- AS
THE REST OF THE BUT CITIES AND
COUNTIES UP TO PROVIDE BENEFITS.
THE CONTINUATION OF TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT.
THAT THE PAID FAMILY BENEFIT --
AND OUR ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE IT WE FOUND THAT THROUGH.
A STUDY AND ALSO LOOKING AT SOME
OF OUR OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
BEEN PARKED UPON.
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAMS THAT
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THAT BENEFIT IS AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
AND WHAT EXACTLY IT IS IS
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT -- WE
ALSO HAVE -- SOME PROGRAMMING
REGARDING THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
MILITARY EXIGENCY TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE BENEFITS.
FOR OF OUR MILITARY FAMILIES AS
THEY A DEAL WITH BEING SENT OFF.
TO FIGHT.
AS WELL AS TO JUST SOME
ADJUSTMENTS.
MAY TWO WILL FUNDS [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
COMMENT LL.
THERE ARE SEVERAL PROPOSALS IN
IN THIS ITEM AND ALL -- FOCUS MY
COMMENTS ON THE THE BCP RELATED
SPECIFICALLY TO THE LENGTHENING
OF THE PAID FAMILY PROGRAM AS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR FROM.
SIX WEEKS TO EIGHT WEEKS -- THE
GOVERNOR NOTES THAT THIS
EXPANSION -- WILL REQUIRE SOME
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES ON AND AS
PART OF THE TRAILER BILL THAT
PUTS INTO PLACE THE EXPANSION
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
TO EXEMPT.
THIS TECHNOLOGY PROJECT FROM THE
STATE'S PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE.
PROCESS WHICH IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S -- I. T.
OVERSIGHT PROCESS I IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO US AT THIS POINT WHY
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT -- WOULD
BE EXEMPTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION FROM ITS OWN IT
OVERSIGHT PROCESS.
ON WE HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT THIS
CONCERN WITH EDT AND THEY
POINTED OUT TO US ON THAT FIRST
AND FOREMOST IN THEIR VIEW THIS
SYSTEM CHANGES RELATIVELY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND THEREFORE
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
CARRIES PRETTY LOW RISK GOING
FROM SIX WEEKS. TO EIGHT WEEKS
ON AND ALSO THE THE INFLAMMATION
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINES RATHER
TIGHT -- THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO GO TO EIGHT WEEKS BY
JULY FIRST OF NEXT YEAR AND SO
MINDFUL OF THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS -- BEEN EXEMPTED
FROM THAT THE PROCESS.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE OF
TIMELINESS AND MEETING THAT
IMPLEMENTATION DATE I'M WE THINK
THERE ARE SOME TRADE OFFS WITH
THIS APPROACH OBVIOUSLY ON THAT
THE POWER PROCESS OF THE PROJECT
PROVE A LIFECYCLE PROCESS.
HELPS ENSURE THAT IT SYSTEM
ENHANCEMENTS ARE SUCCESSFUL --
SO WITHOUT IT THERE SOME REST
THERE -- BUT ON THE OTHER HAND
SOME OF THOSE INSURANCES DO
TAKES MORE TIME -- AND SO THE
QUESTION BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR EXEMPTION
OUT RELATES TO THAT TRADE OFF
ABOUT HITTING THE IMPLEMENTATION
DATE FOR JULY ONE OF NEXT YEAR.
RELATIVE -- TO TAKING STEPS TO
ENSURE THE PROJECT SUCCESS.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
CARING FOR THE CONSIDER THIS
RING HOLD OPEN.
NEXT ITEM IS ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
CAPTURED EXPENDITURE PLAN
.
THAT TO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
TIM RAINY I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE A
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS WE NEED THE WORK FORCE TO
TO DO THE WORK.
IN TRANSFORMING THE THE ECONOMY.
WHICH IS REALLY WHAT THESE
AMBITIOUS GOALS ARE DOING BUT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT BOTH.
RETRAINING ARE IN TRAINING
PEOPLE BUT ALSO PROVIDING ACCESS
TO THE BEST JOBS IN THE STATE
THAT'S THE EQUITY.
AGENDA THAT WE'RE PUSHING.
OUT THE STATE WORKFORCE BOARD
HAS BEEN WORKING ON TWO SEPARATE
INITIATIVES THAT ARE VERY
RELATED -- OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
A AND THOSE INITIATIVES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED.
THAT THEY WORK WE GET GREAT
OUTCOMES THE FIRST IS.
THE THE HYBRID TRAINING
PARTNRSHIPS.
BUT WHEN THE THIRD YEAR WITH
WITH A PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS THE
STATE IN TRANSIT HEALTHCARE
BUILDING MAINTENANCE HOSPITALITY
WATER.
WHERE HOUSING AND PORTS WE
TRAINED OVER A THOUSAND WORKERS
OVER THE COURSE OF THOSE FEW
YEARS -- IT ALL PROJECTS THE
WORKERS ARE AT THE TABLE WITH
MANAGEMENT TO VERY UNIQUE
APPROACH.
OTHER WE TAKE SECTOR BASED
APPROACH. TO CO DESIGN IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS MAC MAP OCCUPATIONAL
CHANGE DUE TO CLIMATE TECHNOLOGY
IN INDUSTRY CHANGE.
APART WITH COMMUNITY GROUPS
WORKFORCE AGENCIES AND SCHOOLS
AND FOCUS ON EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY -- THE CHALLENGES
MOVIE PEOPLE UP.
THROUGHA RE SKILLING IN
EDUCATION BUT THEN ALSO MOVING
PEOPLE IN THROUGH STRONG
PATHWAYS UP ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
FROM DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WHO.
MOST NEED GOOD JOBS OF THE
SECOND ONE IS HIRING
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS WE STARTED
WITH PROP THIRTY NINE FUNDING.
A FEW YEARS AGO BUT TO CREATE
ACCESS TO STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP CONSTRUCTION UP
PROGRAMS A CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS EXCUSE
ME.
MULTI CRAFT PRE PARTNERSHIP
PARTNERSHIPS -- USING THE
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED MC THREE
CURRICULUM.
US OVER THE LAST FORTY FIVE
YEARS WE'VE INVESTED IN TWELVE
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS THE STATE --
OF LOCAL BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL
JOINT APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
COMMITTEE BUT BASS ORGANIZATIONS
WORKFORCE BOARDS I IN SCHOOLS WE
SERVED TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS.
LIKE I SAID ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN
FACT THE TWO STATE BUILDINGS
THAT ARE GOING UP JUST BROKE
GROUND ON THE SECOND ONE WE'VE
GOT A MULTI CRAFT PRE
APPRENTICESHIP CONSTRUCTION.
PROGRAM THAT'S CONNECTED TO
THOSE THOSE PROJECTS OF THE
PEOPLE FROM DISADVANTAGED PARTS
OF SACRAMENTO GET ACCESS TO
THOSE -- WONDERFUL BUT MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS -- THE PROPOSAL.
UP BEFORE YOU EXPENSE WORK IN
THOSE TWO ON THOSE TWO
INITIATIVES THE HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS WERE
EXPANDING THE CAPACITY TO
FOURTEEN REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS.
A TEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
OVER FIVE YEARS -- THE HIGHROAD
TRAINEE PARTNERSHIPS IS ALSO
EXPANDED -- TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR FIVE YEARS --
THAT'LL EXPANDED TWENTY PROJECTS
IN INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED IN THE CLIMATE CHANGE
SCOPING PLAN DEVELOPED BY THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
ADDITIONALLY THE STATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD WILL PILOT TO
HIERO TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS IN
UP PARTS OF THE STATE THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
CLIMATE POLICY.
WHERE THERE ARE IMMINENT?
A MASS DISLOCATIONS A WORKERS --
BUT USING THE SAME MODEL OF
INDUSTRY COMMUNITY.
AND LABOR PARTNERSHIPS -- TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE GET ACCESS TO
IT TOO GREAT JOBS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FINANCE NO COMMENT LL.
ON AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR
JANUARY BUDGET -- THIS PROPOSAL
WAS PRESENTED AND AND SOMEWHAT
SMALLER FORM AT THE TIME ON OUR
OFFICE.
MET WITH THE BOARD AND REVIEWED
THAT PROPOSAL REGARDING THE
FUNDING FOR THE HRT PNH RCC --
AT THE TIME WE COMMENTED THAT
THESE PROGRAMS HAD BEEN IN
OPERATION FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND
APPEARED PREPARED TO BE EXPANDED --
OFTENTIMES OUR OFFICE IS CLOSE
ATTENTION TO TO PROJECTS THAT
AREN'T QUITE READY TO GO -- WILL
CALL IT'S A YOU KNOW THE BIG
LEAGUES ARE SO -- WAS
CONSIDERABLY MORE FUNDING -- BUT
IN THIS CASE IT APPEARED THAT
THEY WERE PREPARED AND THAT THE
BOARD WAS WAS -- WORKING WITH
ITS REGIONAL PARTNERS TO EXPAND
IT ACCORDINGLY SO WE REYES NO
COMMENTS OR NO ISSUES -- WITH
THE PROPOSAL THAT TIME AND THE
SAME IS TRUE TODAY.
IT COMES IN THE COMMITTEE. ONE
OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY RUN THE WHOLE THIS ITEM
OPEN SO THANK YOU THINK I SEE
OUR STATE TREASURER HAS JOINED
US WE'LL GO AHEAD AND JUMP AHEAD
HER ITEM.
ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
FIFTEEN THANK
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM
REQUESTING FROM MY OFFICE
SPECIFICALLY I'M REQUESTING AN
INCREASE FOR GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION BY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
ALONG WITH A CORRESPONDING
DECREASE TO A RE ENFORCEMENT
ALLOCATION.
THE SHIP WILL ASSIST THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE WITH ITS
EFFORT TO APPROPRIATELY REALIGN.
FUNDING BASED ON WORKLOAD
GOVERNMENT CODE AND BEST
PRACTICES.
FURTHERMORE THIS REALIGNMENT
WILL ALLOW THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE TO REDUCE ITS DEPENDENCE
ON REIMBURSEMENTS THUS REDUCING --
MY OFFICES RISK ASSOCIATED WITH
ITS CURRENT UNSUSTAINABLE
FUNDING STRUCTURE.
WE JUST CAME FROM THE SENATE
WHERE THEY APPROVED AS BUDGETED
WITH THE ADDITION OF BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ASKING MY OFFICE TO
REPORT NEXT YEAR.
ON THE OFFICES OVERALL RESOURCE
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING THE
IMPACT OF ANY RECENT WERE
PENDING CHANGES IN
RESPONSIBILITIES SUCH AS THE
IMPACT DUE TO THE LOSS OF THE
WAKE.
WORKLOAD I HOPE THIS BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ADDRESSES THE CONCERNS
OF YOUR STAFF NOTED IN THE STAFF
COMMENTS AND I AM AMENABLE TO
INCLUDING IT [inaudible]
FINANCE.
GOING TO GET OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- WE FEEL PERMANENT
FUNDING IS APPROPRIATE FOR THE
PROBLEM THE TRANSIT OFFICES
FACING.
THIS FUNDING REALIGNMENT ROLL
RIGHT SIZE IT'S FUNDING
STRUCTURE TO BETTER REFLECT ITS
CURRENT BUSINESS NEEDS
[inaudible]
HELLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN BROWN WITH
THE LA OKAY -- WE THINK THAT THE
TREASURE IN INTEREST IN RIGHT
SIDE IN.
THE OFFICE OF BUDGET COULD COULD
VERY WELL MAKE SENSE I THINK OUR
CONCERN IS THAT IT'S A VERY
TECHNICALLY COMPLEX.
A PROPOSAL IN ONE THAT'S BACKED
BY A CONSULTANT REPORT THAT'S
QUITE LENGTHY WE'VE ONLY JUST
STARTED TO REVIEW A IN SO.
OUR THOUGHT IS THAT GIVEN THAT
COMPLEXITY. ONE THING THAT YOU
MIGHT CONSIDER THE PROVING THE
PROPOSAL ON A ONE YEAR BASIS
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE OFFICE. TO
MOVE FORWARD AS PLAN WITHOUT
HAVING TO MAKE ANY OTHER
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES AND
INTENTIONALLY AND THEN -- WOULD
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO GET A
NEW PROPOSAL IN JANUARY WHAT
WHERE WE'D HAVE MORE TIME TO
REVIEW IT AND THEN REPORT BACK
TO YOU.
GIVE ME MORE INFORMATION ON THE
WITH PROPOSAL.
THE WEEK ISSUE.
BY I CAN DO THAT IN THE THIRD
TREASURER WOULD PREFER
[inaudible]
BECKY.
WE HAVE A CONTRACT WITH THE
WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN AND
WE ARE PROCESS VOUCHERS FOR THEM
MRS BEEN ON ONGOING CONTRACT
FIRST QUITE SOME TIME.
THE S. IT.
IS -- GOING AWAY BECAUSE OF THE
ELECTRONIC BENEFITS TRANSFER
PROGRAM SIR PAPER VENTURES ARE
BEING REPLACED BY ELECTRONIC
CARDS.
SO THAT WORKLOAD IS GOING TO GO
AWAY AND IT'S GOING TO CALL THE
CLIENT SIGNIFICANTLY AND THAT
CONTRACT.
IS FOR ABOUT FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
SO THE CONTRACT ALSO SUPPORTS A
LOT OF COST WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT INDIRECT COSTS SUCH
AS THE OUR ADMIN EXECUTIVE AND
IT COST SIR WILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT AND
REDIRECTING THOSE COST WILL
BECAUSE OUR PROGRAM DIVISIONS TO
HAVE TO INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENTS AND THERE ARE A
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH.
THAT NIGHT THANK GOD MISTER
SCHAEFFER CAN SPEAK TO THOSE
REST.
THANK YOU BECKY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- THE SEVERAL OF THE
RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH THE LOSS
OF WICKED BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THE
STATE LEADERSHIP ACCOUNTABILITY --
ACT.
A REPORTS AT THE OFFICES MADE
OUT JUST COVER TWO OF THEM.
AND THE FIRST IS THAT THE STATE
COMPENSATION INSURANCE FUND.
HAS CONSISTENTLY EXPRESSED SOME
DISPLEASURE WITH THE OFFICE ON
THE AMOUNT OF REIMBURSEMENTS WE
SEEK FROM THEM.
AND HAVE REPEATEDLY MENTIONED TO
US THAT THEY WOULD HOPE -- TO
SECURE LEGISLATION TO ENABLE
THEM TO WITHDRAW FROM THE STATE
TREASURY.
THANKFULLY THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED --
AT THIS POINT -- SIMILARLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES -- WHICH IS NOT
REQUIRED -- TO KEEP FUNDS IN THE
STATE TREASURY BECAUSE THESE ARE
NOT STATE REVENUES --
VOLUNTARILY KEEPS FUNDS IN THE
STATE TREASURY.
THE RESULT IS THAT WHAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US IS A PROBLEM OF FIXED
COSTS VERSUS VARIABLE COSTS.
AS THE VARIABLE COSTS GO AWAY
THE FIXED COSTS.
ARE NOT NECESSARY REDUCED.
IN A COMMENSURATE WAY AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT WHAT WEEK I
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN TO THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT.
IS THAT -- WE WOULD -- WE WOULD
SEEK TO AVOID -- KIND OF AN UP
AND DOWN -- PROBLEM WITH THE
FUNDING.
LARGELY BECAUSE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT WOULD HAVE
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE FAMILY. ONE
OF THE INDIRECT COSTS THAT IS --
THAT IS FUNDED IN THIS FASHION
IS THE LOCAL AGENCY INVESTMENT
FUND WHERE REIMBURSEMENTS ARE
DISTRIBUTED.
THROUGHOUT THE A A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS IN THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE LOCAL AGENCY INVESTMENT
FUND.
SERVICES MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
OF CALIFORNIANS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES BY ENABLING THEM TO
INVEST ON TOP OF THE STATE
TREASURER.
SO WE DO -- HAVE SOME DEGREE OF
ANXIETY ABOUT.
BEING TOO VOLATILE IN THE LEVEL
OF REIMBURSEMENTS LAST WE SET
OFF.
AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
HAVING FOLKS WITHDRAW FROM THE
LOCAL AGENCY FUND WE HAVEN'T
QUIDDITY MEET SUCH DEMAND.
BUT IT PROBABLY DOESN'T BENEFIT.
TO THE PROGRAM AT ALL CANNOT BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER OTHER QUESTIONS
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
UNDERSTAND STAFF IS GOING TO
MEET WITH TREASURER STAFF ON THE
SIDE AND COME BACK TO COMMITTEE
NEXT WEEK FOR AN HOUR AND HOLD
OPEN.
NEXT ITEM.
THANK YOU.
I REMEMBER SIX MAYBE VISION
HEALTHY PROPOSAL
CAN YOU MISTER
CHAIR DANIELLE BRANDON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
INCLUDED A ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION PROPOSAL TO JUMPSTART
HOUSING PRODUCTION.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES THAT
SAME COMMITMENT TOM WITH A FEW
KEY CHANGES.
SO WITH REGARD TO THE PLANNING
AND PRODUCTION GRANTS FOR
HOUSING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED MISSED
FIFTY MILLION FOR REGIONAL
PLANNING.
AND FACILITY CONSTRUCTION AND
EXPANSION THE MAY REVISION
MAINTAINS THAT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR REGIONAL PLANNING
THAT'S A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TWO REGIONS AS DEFINED
AND A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE'VE ADDED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION AS ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE PLANNING GRANTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDED FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR INCENTIVE GRANTS FOR
JURISDICTIONS HAVE MADE PROGRESS
IN IMPLEMENTING THEIR PLAN AND
INCREASED HOUSING GOALS.
THE MAY REVISION INSTEAD
PROVIDES FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO
THE INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. TO
PROVIDE GAP FUNDING TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND REHABILITATION
OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS
HIGH DENSITY AFFORDABILITY MIXED
INCOME HOUSING.
I AND SOME OF THE SHORT TERM
GOALS ON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ESTABLISH NEW SHORT TERM GOALS
THE MAY REVISION AMENDS THIS TO
ALIGN THE HOUSING SHORT TERM.
AB SORRY HOUSING SHORT TERM
PRODUCTION GOALS WITH THE
FORTHCOMING SIX CYCLE RENOWNED.
IN ADDITION THE MAY REVISION
CONTINUES TO DEVELOP LONG TERM
REGIONAL HOUSING PRODUCTION
GOALS THE RENEW RINA PROCESS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
MAINTAINS THE LINKAGE TO SB
[inaudible]
ONE FUNDING.
MOVING ON TO THE HOMELESSNESS
AID.
SORRY.
SO WITH HOMICIDE IN PLANNING FOR
SHELTER PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDEDFIVE HUNDRED
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT AND EXPANSION OF
EMERGENCY SHELTERS AND
NAVIGATION CENTERS.
AND PROVIDES INCENTIVES FOR
GRANTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR
MEETING MILESTONES AS OUTLINED --
IN REQUIRED REGIONAL PLANS IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS.
THE MAY REVISION INCREASES THIS
ALLOCATION TO SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION.
M. REMOVES THE INCENTIVE GRANT
MEETING MILESTONES DISTRIBUTION
PROCESS.
THE MAY REVISION CHANGES
DISTRIBUTE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION TO THE THIRTEEN
LARGEST CITIES TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TWO
COUNTIES AND ONE HUNDRED MILLION
TO THE CONTINUUM OF CARE.
MAY REVISION ALLOCATES THESE
BASED ON THAT TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN HOMELESS POINT IN TIME
COUNT AS OPPOSED TO THE PREVIOUS
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN COUNT.
IT ADDS FLEXIBILITY TO HELP
FUNDS CAN BE SPENT IN CALLS OUT
EMERGENCY SHELTERS NAVIGATION
CENTERS.
RAPIDLY HOUSING RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PREVENTION PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING INNOVATIVE
JOB PROGRAMS AND INNOVATIVE
HOUSING PROJECTS AS POTENTIALLY
USE OF FUNDS.
FINALLY THE MAY REVISION MAKES
APPLICATION PROCESS MORE
FLEXIBLE IN ORIGINAL PLANS HAVE
BEEN COMPLETED THEY CAN BE
INCLUDED IN THE APPLICATION.
AND AT THIS TIME I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I WILL.
NEW THIS MORALIS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE OUR
OFFICE RAISED SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET --
REGARDING HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS OVERALL WE THINK
THAT THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
MOVES IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IN PARTICULAR THE RE PURPOSING
OF GENERAL PURPOSE FUNDS TOWARDS
THE INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM AS WELL AS PROVIDING
SPECIFIC HOMELESSNESS SERVICES
WILL ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO
YIELD MORE CERTAIN BENEFITS.
IN ITS EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
HOMELESSNESS -- ONE AREA WHERE
WE STILL WANT TO SORT OF MAKE
NOTE OF IT IS THIS QUESTION
ABOUT HOW THE LEGISLATURE
PRIORITIZES ITS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS FUNDS IN PARTICULAR.
THE GOVERNOR'S DECISION IT TO
EXPAND RESOURCES TOWARDS HIGHER
INCOME LEVELS AND WE'VE SEEN IN
THE PAST INTO THIS CONTINUES TO
BE A POLICY QUESTION BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR DOES NOT REVISED.
THAT ASPECT OF HIS PACKAGE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE THE
STRUCTURE.
SO FIRST LET ME JUST SAY I WANT
TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT AROUND HOUSING
AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
LEVELS OF FUNDING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND DEATHLY DON'T WANT MY
COMMENTS TO ME MISCONSTRUED IN
NOT ME NOT SAYING THAT BIG
PICTURE THANK YOU -- ONE
QUESTION I HAD AROUND THE IN
FILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM SO WHAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT CONVERSATIONS ARE
HAPPENING AROUND TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT AND I
WANTED TO ASK IF TRANSIT
AGENCIES WOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY
FOR THE FUNDING AND THE SPECIFIC
CONTEXT IS.
LAST YEAR GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE
WHICH WOULD STREAMLINED HOUSING
PRODUCTION ON PART OWN SURFACE
PARKING LOTS AND SO.
TRANSIT SYSTEM IS NOW
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL BUT
DOESN'T HAVE FUNDING FOR
PLANNING OR STAFFING AND JUST
THAT PARTICULAR BILL ALONE COULD
RESULT IN THIRTY THOUSAND NEW
UNITS OF HOUSING IN THE BAY AREA.
WITH AT LEAST A THIRD OF THAT
BEING AVAILABLE -- TO TO LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS SO.
AT THE LEAST I'D LIKE TO ASK AND
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME
CONVERSATIONS AROUND WHETHER
BART COULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING. FOR IMPLEMENTING A LAW
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR HOUSING
PRODUCTION ON PART OWNED LAND
BUT MORE GENERALLY I'D LIKE TO
ASK A QUESTION OF WHETHER THIS
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE INVOLVED IN
PLANNING FOR HOUSING -- UNDER
THE UNDER THAT TRANSIT ARE IN
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM OF TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
ALONG WITH DEVELOPERS FOR THAT
FOR THE CONNECTIONS BUT UNDER
THE AYE AYE G. PROGRAM.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT TRANSIT AGE
I WOULD LET ME DOUBLE CHECK TO
COME BUT I DON'T BELIEVE THE
TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE ELIGIBLE
OPTIONS AND OF THE INFIRM --
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAMS
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A SPECIFIC
REQUEST THAT THAT BE CONSIDERED
AND IF IT'S POSSIBLE THERE ARE
DEVELOPER THE HOUSING NORMALLY
WE WOULD OR THE THEY WERE
DEVELOPER THEY WOULD BE THAT
WOULD BE MANAGING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE PLAN IT IS
PART OWN LAND.
SO IT'S UP TO THEM AT THIS
MOMENT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THAT AND THEY'RE IN. TWO DOZEN
CONVERSATIONS -- AROUND TWENTY
SIX PART STATIONS AND ALL THE
CALIFORNIA HOW TO DO THAT AND
IT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT --
BOOST TO TO HOUSING PRODUCTION
SO AT MY OFFICE HAPPY TO CHAT
WITH YOU ABOUT THIS FURTHER BUT
LIKE TO ENGAGE WITH YOU ON THIS
ACCOUNT.
NOT SERVE YOU COULD GET BACK TO
US ON A KIND OF AN ANSWER THE
BIG RIGHT.
ON THE OTHER SIDE TO QUESTIONS I
HAVE -- PIGGY BACK ON THE ALLEY
OWES QUESTIONS AROUND
HOMELESSNESS -- SO FIRST AGAIN I
JUST WANT TO SAY THE COMMITMENT
OF THE LEVEL OF FUNDING THAT YOU
ARE.
GOING TO PUT INTO HOMELESSNESS
IS IS FANTASTIC I KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS CHARACTERIZED
THE MONEY AS GOING TO ONE TIME
INTERVENTIONS -- BUT THERE ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE RESTRICTIONS
OF FLEXIBILITY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO RESPOND HOMELESSNESS
AND THE REALITY IS THIS IS THE
SECOND YEAR OF SO CALLED ONE
TIME FUNDING -- AND I THINK
THEY'RE JUST CONCERNED TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT FOR SPENDING THIS
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT IT BE PUT
TO TO BEST USE AND I THINK WE
ALL SHARE THAT.
SO THE QUESTION I HAVE IS WITH
THE LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER BILL
PRECLUDE ANY OF THE
JURISDICTIONS CITY COUNTY
CONTINUANCE OF CARE.
FROM USING FUNDING FOR
INTERVENTIONS LIKE.
THE OPERATING EXPENSES OF A
SHELTER OR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT LONGER TERM RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PERSONS RAPID RE
HOUSING AND INCENTIVES TO
LANDLORDS. TO ACCEPT TENANTS AND
WONDERING IF YOU COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE EFINITIONS
OF THE LISTS OF USES FOR THESE
FUNDS.
SURE AND SO WE HAVE MADE THE
USES A LOT MORE FLEXIBLE WITH
REGARD TO THOSE SPECIFIC I DON'T
BELIEVE THOSE ARE SPECIFICALLY
CALLED OUT I DON'T KNOW -- I'LL
HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK THE
LANGUAGE I'M SORRY JUST.
WE RELEASED IT LAST NIGHT AND
I'M STILL SETTING UP ON IT
MYSELF AND BUT WE DO HAVE.
SOME LATE NIGHT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING I'M SORRY Là LATE NIGHT
SO YEAH -- BUT WE HAVE WE HAVE
EXPANDED THESE USES INTO AREAS
WHERE THEY CAN BE USED AS ONE
TIME FINDINGS AND BE MOST
EFFECTIVELY IS STE OKAY.
I THINK WHAT I WILL SAY IS I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LIST.
OF THE USE OF FUNDS THAT INCLUDE
REAL EVIDENCE BASED APPROACHES
FOR MOVING PEOPLE OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS.
SO LONG TERM RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROJECT BASED HOUSING VOUCHERS
THAT ARE TIED TO SUPPORT HOUSING.
OPERATING SUBSIDIES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
I'LL JUST GIVE THE EXAMPLE THAT
RAPID RE HOUSING WHILE IT'S BEEN
USEFUL FOR SOME FOLKS HAS NOT
BEEN AS EFFECTIVE AS I THINK WE
ALL ANTICIPATED BECAUSE IT'S
TIME LIMITED.
AND AT THE END OF THE ASSISTANCE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE AN AFFORDABLE
PLACE TO MOVE AND SO.
MY HOPE IS THAT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE EXPLICITLY REQUIRES
PROGRAM FUNDS TO BE SPENT ON
INTERVENTIONS THAT MOVE PEOPLE
TOWARD PERMANENT HOUSING
SOLUTIONS -- AND THEN ONE THING
I ACTUALLY LIKE TO ASK THAT BUT
I HOPE IS IS NOT DIFFICULT AS I
HOPE THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES A REPORT
BACK. TO ALL OF US ON THE USE OF
FUNDS AND SPECIFICALLY HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN MOVED INTO.
PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS --
IF WE'RE GONNA SPEND YOU KNOW
HALF BILLION LAST YEAR AND SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR.
WE NEED TO KNOW FROM LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHAT'S WORKING SO
THAT NEXT YEAR IF WE HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION WHICH WE PROBABLY
WELL.
WE KNOW WHERE THE BEST ON THE
MONEY I DON'T THINK ANYONE KNOWS
THAT AT THIS POINT BASED ON WHAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR AND WE LIKE
TO FIGURE THAT OUT. ONE LAST
THING I KNOW WHO -- THE
TROUBLING PATROL BILL LANGUAGE
IS NOT A COME OUT ON THE LOW
INCOME TAX BLOG HOUSING TAX
CREDIT RIGHT THAT THAT WAS NOT
AGENDAS FOR TODAY'S MEETING.
TEL AVIV MORALS ASSEMBLY BUDGET
IT IT CAME OUT AND THEN I GOT
PULLED BACK THE RELATING TO SEE
THE REVISED VERSION.
BUT WE WERE TALKING WE JUST
WANTED THEM TO THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT ANY OF IT.
OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING THAT YOU
WANT TO SET THIS POINT ON HOW
YOU'RE PLANNING TO RESOLVE THE
ISSUES THAT ARE SWIRLING AROUND
THE TAX FOR IT.
AND THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS
Sí
CREDIT REALLY AND I JUST KNOW
THAT WE ARE TAUGHT WE TOOK IT
DOWN SO THAT BECAUSE WE REALIZE
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT NEED
TO BE TAUGHT -- CHANGED A NET
AND WORKING ON THOSE AND WILL BE
POSTED AGAIN ONCE WE'VE REACHED
DECISIONS ON APPRECIATE THAT I'D
LET ME JUST TOUCH ON A FEW
ISSUES THAT I'LL BE LOOKING AT
WHICH IS.
ONE I UNDERSTAND.
THAT THE TRAILER BILL IS MAYBE
PROPOSED A 30% CREDIT AS OPPOSED
TO A 50% CREDIT -- HAVE
QUESTIONS AROUND THAT -- WE KNOW
THAT THE HIGHER CREDITS USUALLY
NEEDED FOR HIGHER COST AREAS TO
PROVIDE ENOUGH SUBSIDIES SO --
SKEPTICAL ABOUT WHETHER THE
LOWER AMOUNT IS THE RIGHT ONE
AND I WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WHAT DATA.
OUT WHAT THAT WILL ENTAIL.
THE SECOND THING I WANT TO
MENTION IS JUST ENSURING THAT
FOR THE CREDIT TO BE EFFECTIVE
THAT IT BE ON GOING -- I KNOW
YOU'RE VERY WHERE THE FACT THAT --
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL AS OLD AS A
LOW IS A SIGNIFICANT AND
APPRECIATED ONE TIME FUNDING
PROPOSAL WHERE THE BROADER
HOUSING COMMUNITY BELIEVES IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE HOUSING TAX
CREDIT MARKET. FOR THERE TO BE
ONGOING STREAMS OF FUNDING SO.
AGAIN HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH YOU
ON THAT -- AND THEN MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE TROLL BILL
LANGUAGE WILL PROPOSE A WARNING
THE CREDIT ON A FIRST COME FIRST
SERVE BASIS WITHOUT COMPETITION.
AND I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
CONCERNS AND BEEN RAISED ABOUT
IF YOU DON'T HAVE COMPETITION
HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT PROJECTS
ARE GOING TO BE QUALITY PROJECTS.
SO -- LOVE TO AND HELP YOU GAUGE
WITH US YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT IT
BUT OBVIOUSLY Và COMES OUT WITH
SOME OF THOSE ASPECTS I WILL
HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS ON THAT
SO JUST WANNA SAY THAT UP FRONT.
AND I'M GONNA FOR MY TWO CENTS
IN WOULD ALLOW FOR HOMELESS IS
THAT'S GREAT.
I'M A STILL NOT DOING SO SOME OF
THE ROOT ISSUES WITH GUARDING
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE THOSE ARE BIG ISSUES WITH
THAT THIS IS.
THAT'S ALL PART OF THE FRAMEWORK
BUT A MYSTERY ONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS -- WE'VE MUCH
APPRECIATE THE REVISED
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL COMING
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AND ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT BROADLY AND ARE
STILL LOOKING.
INTO THE DETAILS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND YOUR
AUNT WE WILL TRY YOUR AUNT'S WE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI WE
SUPPORT THE MAYOR'S MY REVISED
PROPOSAL ON HOUSING HOMELESSNESS.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY ALSO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JOSH DUGGAR REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND TODAY ON BEHALF OF
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE URBAN
CAUGHT.
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA --
RELATIVE TO THE HOUSING PROPOSAL
WE SUPPORT THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR HOUSING RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
IT'S AVAILABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
PROJECTS IN UNINCORPORATED AREAS
RELATIVE TO THE HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL WE WANT EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT AND APPRECIATION
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S REVISED
PROPOSAL ON HOMELESSNESS.
SPECIFICALLY WE SUPPORT THE
INCREASE FLEXIBILITY TIED TO THE
PROPOSAL THE INCREASE FUNDING
OVERALL IN THE DIRECT ALLOCATION
OF TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO COUNTIES.
AND AS WELL AS THE TO USE OF THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN POINT TIME
COUNTS.
WE REALLY WANT TO REITERATE THAT
THE DIRECT ALLOCATION TO COUNTY
IS SHOULD BE VIEWED NOT JUST AS
A SIDE ROAD PROJECTS.
LED BY COUNTIES BUT AS
INVESTMENTS IN SYSTEM LEVEL
COLLABORATIVE APPROACHES TO AND
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU. FOR
FINANCE WITH RESPECT TO THE
HOMELESS FUNDING CAN EXPLAIN
WHAT THE GOVERNOR ADDED A NEW
PART OF FUNDING FOR COUNTIES.
IN WITH THE COUNTIES HAVING THE
PRIMARY ROLE OF SERVICES.
HOW WILL THEY USE THIS FUNDING?
SURE AND SO WITH THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE HEAP FUNDING
I'M THE PLAN WITH THE REGIONAL
PLANS WAIT THERE IS AN INDICATED
NEED FOR COUNTIES BECAUSE THEY
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL ROLE IN THOSE
REGIONAL PLANNING -- THAT.
PORTIONS BY APOLOGIES -- SO THEY
WILL NEED FUNDING FOR THAT AND
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
A THEIR INDIVIDUAL ROLE IN THE
REGIONAL PLANNING IS A NEED AND
IN ADDITION WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE STILL
WORKING WITH THE KEEP FUNDING.
WE DON'T WANT TO INUNDATE THEM
TOO MUCH WITH TOO MUCH FUNDS
[inaudible]
WE SPREAD OUT THAT'S WHY.
WHO'S IN CHARGE THE PLANNING
THAN FOR THE REGIONAL HOUSING.
THE REGIONAL PLANS I'M SORRY.
WHO'S IN CHARGE YES MENTION IT
SHOULD BE A GROUP EFFORT BETWEEN
ALL OF THE PARTIES WITHIN THE
REGION.
IS IT A TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
CAN I DOUBLE CHECK AND GET BACK
TO YOU ARE NOT ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU.
THERE WERE HOLES AUTUMN OPEN.
EVEN ANSWER TODAY OR I'LL GET
BACK TO THIS AFTERNOON YES RIGHT
HERE OKAY -- SADDAM OPEN OUR
NEXT ISSUE IS UNDER SEVEN
HOMELESS COORDINATING A FINANCE
COUNCIL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JENNY PARTY FOOT THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL.
OF THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION --
REQUEST NINE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND GENERAL FUND AND
SIX POSITIONS.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
TWENTY AND THEN.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND FIVE HUNDRED AND THREE
THOUSAND AND THREE POSITIONS ON
GOING. TO EXPAND THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL. THREE OF THE PROPOSED
POSITIONS WOULD BE LIMITED TERM --
FOR TWO YEARS TO CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTING KEEP NOW THAT THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS HAS
BEEN DISBURSED -- THE STAFF NEED
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT AND MONITORING TO BE
SURE THAT HE FUNDS ARE USED
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY.
IN ADDITION TO THESE THREE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS WE ARE
REQUESTING THREE PERMANENT STAFF
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO SUPPORT.
THE ONGOING ADMINISTRATIVE AND
PROGRAM ACTIVITIES FOR THE
COUNCIL.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THIS
PROPOSAL DOES NOT INCLUDE
STAFFING AND SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSED NEW GRANT PROGRAM.
THOSE COSTS WOULD BE COVERED BY
THE PROPOSED 5% ALLOCATION FOR
STATE OPERATIONS I'D BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE MORE DETAILS OR ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
OIL.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU'RE LOOKING FORWARD WITH.
EXCUSE ME MR AGAIN LOOKING
FORWARD WELL THE STAFF ALSO HELP
MR THE NEW PROGAM IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE.
NO THESE FUNDS WOULD NOT BE USED
FOR ADMINISTERING THE NEW
PROGRAM.
ADMINISTRATING AND STAFFING
COSTS FOR THE PROPOSED NEW
PROGRAM WOULD COME OUT OF THE 5% --
ALLOCATION FOR STATE OPERATIONS
THAT IS INCLUDED IN TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THAT PROGRAM.
SO THIS WOULD BE ONGOING SUPPORT
FOR THE COUNCIL'S MANDATES --
AND IMPLEMENTING HEAT FOR THE
THE DURATION OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM ARE THE PROGRAMS PRETTY
SIMILAR LOW -- THEY ARE SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR BUT THERE ARE SOME
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES OF ONE
IS THE ADDITION OF COUNTIES IS
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS.
SO THE NUMBER OF GRANTEES WILL
INCREASE FROM THE FORTY FOUR
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE AND ELEVEN
LARGE CITIES THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR HEAP. TO THE THIRTEEN LARGE
CITIES THE FORTY FOUR CONTINUES
OF CARE AND THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES SO THAT'S AN INCREASE.
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
ADDITION THE REGIONAL PLANS THAT
ARE REQUIRED.
IN ORDER -- TO GET ACCESS TO
THESE NEW FUNDS WILL REQUIRE
SOME WORKLOAD AND SOME REVIEW BY
THE COUNCIL STAFF TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- THOSE PLANS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROPOSED USE
OF THE NEW GRANT PROGRAM FUNDS
THAT'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
ENTITIES DOING THEIR OWN THING
SHOULDN'T IT BE MORE COORDINATED
VERSES ARE PRETTY.
WELL THE TEAM WILL BE LED BY
SOMEONE WHO WILL BE OVERSEEING
BOTH OF THE GRANT PROGRAMS SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED FROM HE IS THAT.
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERSHIPS IS REALLY -- REALLY
AN IMPORTANT ROLE AND THAT THE
GRANT MANAGEMENT ROLE CAN BE
PERFORMANCE YOU KNOW UNDER THAT
KIND OF THE PROGRAM IF YOU WILL
THAT LOCAL PARTNERSHIP CAP --
AND SO WE WOULD PROPOSE TO HAVE
THE GRANT MANAGER FOR HEAP --
AND THEN A NEW GRANT MANAGER FOR
THE NEW PROPOSED PROGRAM.
THAT'S LOW NEW GRANTEES FOR THE
PROGRAM NOT THE STAFF CORRECT.
A THAT'S CORRECT.
IF I UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION
CORRECTLY MISTER CHAIR.
YES.
IT'S IT WOULD BE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF THE GRANTEES BUT NOT
STAFF NOT STAFF NOT CURRENTLY.
THAT WOULD THAT THE PROPOSED
STAFF WE HAVEN'T ACTUALLY
REVIEWED AND DONE THE ANALYSIS
YET TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH
ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR THE NEW
PROGRAM WOULD BE REQUIRED IN
STORE EXPECTATION IS THAT.
THE 5% THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
GRANT PROGRAM FOR STATE
OPERATIONS WOULD BE MORE THAN
SUFFICIENT TO COVER ADDITIONAL
COSTS RIGHT BUT THAT WILL GO
BACK TO MY POINT EVERYONE DOING
THEIR OWN THING AND NOT BEING
COORDINATED.
TOGETHER THEY'LL ALL STILL BE
UNDER THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY AND WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE COUNCIL AND
WHAT IS THE OVERSIGHT CONSIST OF
HELL.
HOW MUCH OVER CIDER MINIMAL ONE
OF THE NEW ONE OF THE NEW
PROPOSED PERMANENT POSITIONS
WOULD BE A NEW DEPUTY SECRETARY
WHO WOULD FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
THE HOMELESSNESS INITIATIVES --
THAT ARE OVERSEEN BY AGENCY
CURRENTLY BOTH THE HOUSING
PORTFOLIO AND THE HOMELESSNESS
PORTFOLIO ARE OVERSEEN BY ONE
PERSON ONE DEPUTY SECRETARY.
AND SO GIVEN THE INCREASE IN
ATTENTION -- IN THE NEW PROGRAMS
THAT ARE BEING -- INITIATED.
AGENCY WOULD PROPOSE TO HAVE
THOSE TWO THAT ONE POSITION
SPLIT INTO TWO HIGH LEVEL DEPUTY
SECRETARIES TO REALLY OVERSEE.
THE HOMELESS IS PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE HOW THE COUNCIL
HEAP.
AND THE NEW PROGRAM.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REYNOLDS AUTUMN OPEN THANK YOU
ALL THANK YOU MISTER MOVE ON
ITEM NUMBER -- EIGHT PROP ONE
SORT OF PROGRAM CONFORMITY
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS IF THEY KNOW CASTILLO AT
THE HOUSING COMMUNITY ELEMENT
BUDGET OFFICE.
THE JONES SOONER JUNIOR FARM
WORKER PROGRAM PROVIDES GRANTS
AND LOANS TO FINANCE A NEW
CONSTRUCTION REHABILITATION AN
ACQUISITION OF OWNER OCCUPIED
AND MULTI FAMILY RENTAL HOUSING
FOR AGRICULTURE WORKERS.
WITH THE PRIORITY FOR LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THE CITY REQUEST TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO IMPROVE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE JOKES RUN
A PROGRAM -- SPECIFICALLY TO
MAXIMIZE FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
FORMER HOUSING BUT WAIT.
FORMER HOUSING STREAMLINED
ADMINISTRATION OF LONG TERM
MONITORING AND TO CONFORM CENTER
PROGRAM RETIREMENTS REQUIREMENTS.
TWO OTHER ECT MISTER MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAMS.
WITH THAT WILL ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU.
NO L. L..
CONCERNS QUESTIONS MCCURRY.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ASYLUM.
CARILLO SADDAM OPEN THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM NUMBER.
NINE DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY.
THIS ROLES PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LARGER DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY MAY REVISION PACKAGE.
IT INCLUDES RESEARCH RESOURCES
FOR VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS TO
ENHANCE THE STATE'S INVESTORS
RESPONSE PREPAREDNESS AND
SUPPORT THE CONTINUITY OF STATE
GOVERNMENT DURING DISASTERS IN
THIS PROPOSAL.
EACH CITY REQUEST TWO MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND BUDGET AUTHORITY IN
FOR POSITIONS FOR THE FOLLOWING.
BY NOON FIFTY THOUSAND TO
ESTABLISH A GRANTS MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM EIGHT HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND FOR FOR POSITIONS FOR
PERMANENT DISASTER RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY UNIT.
IN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TO
REFORM LOCAL NEEDS ASSESSMENT
AND DATA COMPILATION RELATED TO
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN CAMP EMBASSY
FIVE WILL POP FAIRS.
IN THAT ONE SIR ANY QUESTIONS
YOU L. L. [inaudible]
SELECT COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC CAMILLUS ITEM.
CARRILLO SIDE OPEN THANK YOU.
NEXT ISSUE IS A NUMBER TEN XXI
ITS EXECUTIVE ORDER.
IT'S PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S STRATEGY TO
DRESS THE STATE'S HOUSING
SHORTAGE AND AFFORDABILITY
PRESSURES THE GOVERNMENT ISSUED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER IN JANUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN THAT REQUIRES A
CITY TO WORK IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES. TO DEVELOP AN
INVENTORY STATE ON PROPERTY THAT
IS SUITABLE FOR DEVELOPMENT OF
FORMER HOUSING.
ISSUE REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS
OFFERING LONG TERM LEASES TO
DEVELOPERS.
SAYS PROPOSED LEASES FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER CRITERIA ENSURE GOALS OF
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ACCOMPLISHED.
SETTING STAY ON LAND AVAILABLE
FOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT WILL.
EXPEDITE THE MOMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
TO EIGHT UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES --
ADEQUATE FUNDING STAFFING AND
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE ANY TO
EFFECTIVELY DEPLOY THIS NEW
HOUSING OPTION SO EACH CITY IS
REQUESTING A PREPARATION THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND IN
ONGOING SEAT OPERATIONS.
THE BUDGET OR TO IMPLEMENT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON SI DON'T MIND.
LL.
THE CUSTOMER FINANCES NOT TO A
TRADITIONAL ROLE FOR A CD HOW
WILL ISSUE THE MANAGE THIS NEW
ROLE WITH THIS CURRENT COMPETING
INTERESTS -- THIS IS A BIT OF A
NEW ROLE FOR US WE HAVE FUNDED
DEVELOPMENTS RATHER THAN ISSUED
ARE A PIECE FOR SITES BUT
BETWEEN BRING ON THREE STAFF
PEOPLE THAT WILL.
HAVE.
SOME EXPERIENCE IN IN -- SITE
RFPS AND ALSO A PART OF THE
PROPOSAL TO BRING A CONSULTANT
TO WITH THE G. S. WHO WOULD.
WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE US
A LOT OF ASSISTANCE IN THAT
REGARD SO WITH THOSE TWO THINGS
WE BELIEVE WE CAN BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS PROGRAM?
ANY QUESTIONS MCCARTY.
HELLO COME ON THIS ITEM.
GIVEN ALL THIS OPEN.
THIS IS TO OUR NEXT ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN STATE HOUSING ENFORCEMENT.
SURPRISED TO THE PASSAGE OF AB
SEVENTY TWO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE PROCESS FOR FORCING HOUSING
I WENT LAW.
IN OTHER HOUSING RELATED LAWS
WAS DEPENDENT ON THE RESOURCES
OF THIRD PARTY ORGANIZATIONS TO
CHALLENGE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ACTIONS IN THE COURTS NOW.
AB SEVENTY TWO ALLOWS EASY TO
REVOKE IS FINDING THAT A
JURISDICTION IS IN SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED HOUSING ELEMENT.
AND FOR THE NINE COMPLAIN
COMPLAIN JURISDICTION TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR LEGAL
ACTION.
THE SPACE TO THESE NEW AUTHORITY
TO REFER CASES TO THE TRAIN
GENERAL WILL RESERVE.
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
SO A CITY IS REQUESTING ONE
MILLION FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND IN GENERAL FUND BUDGET
AUTHORITY TO COMPENSATE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR COSTS
INCURRED AS A RESULT OF THIS
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD.
THANK YOU L. L. HISTORY.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
THE COMING THIS ITEM.
GIVEN HOW THIS OPEN.
WHICH IS TO OUR NEXT ISSUE.
A NUMBER TWELVE INTERNATIONAL
TRADE PROGRAM SPECIALIST
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M JIM T. AND I'M CHIEF
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
IN OUR RESPONDENTS OF FOR THESE
ISSUES ARE NOT HERE THEY'RE AT
THE SENATE HEARING RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT WERE EXPECTING BE HERE
VERY SHORTLY IF WE CAN JUST HAVE
SOME MORE TIME SO WE'RE SO WILL
BY PASS YOU YOU BYPASS THAT WE'D
APPRECIATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
YES.
THEY SHOULD BE HERE SHORTLY.
OKAY REGULAR OFFICE OF TAX BILLS
ADDITIONAL STAFFING RESOURCES
ISSUE NUMBER.
SIXTEEN WELL THEY ARE HERE
EITHER.
THERE ALSO OKAY
. FOR THIS IS THE
WORD PRESENT ON
SIXTEEN SO WE'RE
ON ISSUE NUMBER.
SIXTEEN MY MISTER CHAIR.
MARK [inaudible]
ARCHIVAL.
I AM THE AFTER THE OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS AND WITH ME IS CHIEF
COUNSEL CHRISTIAN KANE AMONG
RIGHT.
AND THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
THEORY MARTIN ON MY LEFT.
WE HAVE A WORKLOAD REQUEST FOR
YOU AND IN MAY BECAUSE THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME THAT WOULD ENABLE.
TO ASSESS THE WORKLOAD FOR OVER
AN ENTIRE YEAR PERIOD TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL.
OF RESOURCES ASAS YOU KNOW WE
HEAR APPEALS FROM -- THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD OR ACTIONS
TAKEN BY CTF A THE A DEPARTMENT
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
WERNER SEVENTEENTH MONTH -- AND
WE POSTED APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED PINIONS ON OUR WEBSITE
DEALING WITH.
PERSONAL INCOME TAXES
CORPORATION TAXES SALES AND USE
TAX IS AN EXCISE TAXES -- WE
HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
ACTIVE CASES THROUGHOUT THE
APPEALS PROCESS -- AND AGAIN
WE'RE COMING BEFORE YOU WITH THE
WORKLOAD REQUEST AND MIST --
MARTIN IS GOING TO GO THROUGH
BRIEFLY AT A HIGH LEVEL EACH OF
THE FOUR COMPONENTS FOR THOSE
AND THEN WERE OPENED ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT.
THE OFFICE -- AND OR RBC P.
REQUEST [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON -- TAY'S
REQUESTING TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH INCLUDES
PERMANENT POSITION AUTHORITY FOR
THIRTEEN POSITIONS AND FUNDING
TO HELP SUPPORT OUR APPEALS
PROCESSING EDUCATION IN AGENCY
OPERATIONS. FOR THE HEARINGS
DIVISION WHAT WE'RE REQUESTING
IS.
FUNDING AND PERMANENT POSITION
AUTHORITY FOR TO ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE THREE POSITIONS AND
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THREE
CLASSIFICATION OF TO EXISTING
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE OF ONE
AND POSITIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE THREE
LEVEL. FOR OUR FOUNDATIONS
DIVISION.
WERE REQUESTING FIVE ATTORNEYS.
ONE ATTORNEY FIVE ONE TAX
COUNSEL. FOR TWO TAX COUNSEL
THREE LEVEL POSITIONS AND ONE
TAX COUNSEL.
ALSO ONE BUSINESS TAXES
SPECIALIST.
THREE AND ONE STAFF SERVICES
ANALYST. FOR THE CASE MANAGEMENT
DIVISION WE'RE REQUESTING.
FUNDING AND PERMANENT POSITION
OF AUTHORITY FOR THE ASSOCIATE
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM ANALYST AND
ONE FOR THE STAFF SERVICES
ANALYST TO SUPPORT THE GROWING
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE FIT
APPEALS PROCESSING.
AND THEN LAST -- WERE ALSO
ASKING FOR ADMINISTRATION
DIVISION.
AN SSA FOR THE BUSINESS SERVICES
UNIT AND AN ASSOCIATE
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM ANALYST IN
THE HUMAN RESOURCES UNIT.
YOUR PRIVILEGES OF REQUEST WOULD
HELP US PLACE -- OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS IN A POSITION WHERE
WORKLOAD PROCESSES.
AND MORE ADEQUATELY BALANCED WAS
A CHRISTIAN STAFF RESOURCES
THROUGHOUT THE AGENCY
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
HOW WE SUPPORT THE ME REVISED
PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT PROVIDES THE --
OFFICE OF TAX BILLS WITH THE
MUCH NEEDED STAFFING TO MEET THE
APPEALS WORKLOAD.
HELLO.
NO CONCERNS.
A PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
KAREN HOLD OPEN.
THEY SELL MISSION SEVENTEEN
SMALL BUSINESS TAX CODE
STREAMLINING OKAY THE TRAILER
BILL BEFORE YOU ALLOWS THE
FRANCHISE TAX CASES THAT ARE
LESS THAN FIVE THOUSAND TOTAL
AMOUNT.
WERE SMALL BUSINESS TAX CASES
LESS THAN FIFTY THOUSAND DISPUTE.
TO BE HEARD BY ONE OFFICER TAX
APPEALS.
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE THIS
WILL WILL ALLOW SMALLER LESS
COMPLEX CASES TO BE HEARD.
AND SELDOM MORE EXPEDITIOUS
MANNER.
AND AT THIS TIME I'D BE GLAD. TO
FOR QUESTIONS [inaudible]
LL.
WE HAVE NO ISSUES TO RAISE
OURSELVES WE DO NOTE THE CONCERN
RAISED IN THE STAFF COMMENTS IN
THE AGENDA AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
WISHES TO CONSIDER SUCH ISSUES.
WE WOULD CERTAINLY NOT
DISCOURAGE YOU FROM TAKING YOUR
TIME WITH THE PROPOSAL.
WHICH OF THOSE REALLY WOULD LIKE
TO GO THE POLICY COMMITTEE TO
HAVE MORE TIME TO VENT IT OUT --
ANY PUBLIC COME ON THIS ITEM.
KAREN HOLD OPEN.
THANK YOU.
WHICH TAKES US TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE INTERNATIONAL TRADE
BUSINESS SPECIALIST
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR.
AND KRISTA RESCUE CHIEF DEPUTY
OVER ECHO BIZ AND I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY COLLEAGUE BUT CALL
AGAIN THE SENIOR ADVISER FOR
NATIONAL AFFAIRS AND TRADE --
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIR COOPER --
AS A CHRIS SAID IM BUT CALL
AGAIN I'M SENIOR ADVISOR FOR
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND TRADE.
OF THE BCP FOR THREE
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
INVESTMENT SPECIALISTS IS
FOCUSED ON INCREASING THE
CAPACITY.
OF THE INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS
UNIT OF GO BIZ.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. ONE IN
FIVE JOBS IN THE STATE DEPENDS
ON INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
INVESTMENT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THREE
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTMENT IN
INTERNATIONAL TRADE HAS BEEN
MINIMAL.
AND THE RESULTS ARE EVIDENT.
DECLINING SHARE OF EXPORTS FROM
14% IN TWO THOUSAND AND 4211% IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
DECLINING SHARE OF FOREIGN
DIRECT INVESTMENT FROM 25% IN.
2015215% AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT
THE SAME TIME OTHER STATES HAVE
INVESTED HEAVILY.
IN ARE GAINING SHARE. FORTY OF
FIFTY STATES HAVE INTERNATIONAL
TRADE SPECIALISTS.
WHEN CALIFORNIA ELIMINATED MOST
OF ITS INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
INVESTMENT SPENDING IN?
TWO THOUSAND THREE THE WORLD WAS
NOT CONNECTED LIKE IT IS TODAY.
THE INTERNET WAS IN ITS INFANCY.
CHINA WAS NOT THE ECONOMIC POWER
IT IS TODAY.
OTHER STATES HAD NOT RAMPED UP
THEIR INTERNATIONAL TRADE
EFFORTS.
TIMES HAVE CHANGED AND
CALIFORNIA MUST CHANGE WITH THEM
IF IT WANTS TO MAINTAIN ITS
SHARE.
OF WORLD TRADE AND INVESTMENT.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
L. L..
BRENT WITH THE FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THE AS IT AS DESCRIBED IN THE
AGENDA THE STATE'S TRY ATTRACT
TECHNOLOGY TRADE AND COMMERCE
AGENCY ONCE HAD AN EXTENSIVE
INTERNATIONAL TRADE.
PROMOTION ACTIVITIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE WHEN THAT
AGENCY WAS ABOLISHED -- OUR
OFFICE ROUTE ON THAT.
THAT WE LONG HAD QUESTIONED THE
VALUE AND IMPACT OF MANY OF THE
AGENCY'S PROGRAMS.
WE FOUND THAT EVEN AT PEAK
FUNDING.
THE STATE STREET AGENCY PROGRAMS
ASSISTED ONLY A VERY SMALL
PORTION.
OF TARGETED.
INDUSTRIES ARE BUSINESSES.
AND WE SPECIFICALLY NOTED THAT
TRADE PROMOTION ACTIVITIES.
CONSISTENTLY FAILED TO
DEMONSTRATE A CLEAR IMPACT.
ON EXPORTS OR FOREIGN INVESTMENT.
OVER THAT PERIOD OF THE LATE
EIGHTIES NINETIES INTO THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS.
WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
STATE INVOLVEMENT IS UNNECESSARY.
IN MOST INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS
TRANSACTIONS.
THERE ARE MANY FACTORS THAT
AFFECT A STATE SHARE.
OF INTERNATIONAL EXPORTS AND
FOREIGN DIRECT INVESTMENT.
AND WE ARE SKEPTICAL THAT THE
RESOURCES REQUESTED BY GOBIZ
WOULD HAVE MUCH OF AN EFFECT ON
THAT TREND THAT.
THAT THE GOV IS MENTIONED JUST
RECENTLY.
MOREOVER TO THE EXTENT THAT
COMPANIES CANNOT SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSACT BUSINESS IN FOREIGN
MARKETS ON THEIR OWN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL TRADE
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
STATISTICAL INFORMATION OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES AND RESOURCES AND
ASSISTANCE.
SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REQUEST FOR
THESE -- THREE POSITIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON THE SIDE OF MISTER
CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S LOUISE PORT DEAL WITH THE
INLAND EMPIRE ECONOMIC
PARTNERSHIP.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS I E. P. --
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
GO BUSINESS PROPOSALS TO
ESTABLISH THE THREE
INTERNATIONAL PROGRAM TREAT
SPECIALIST POSITIONS AS YOU
HEARD.
YOU KNOW DESPITE CALIFORNIA'S
GROWTH TO BECOME THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
OUR SHARE OF EXPORTS IS GOING
DOWN OR SHARE FOREIGN DIRECT
INVESTMENT IS GOING DOWN THE
IDEA THAT WE SHOULD JUST
CONTINUE IN JUST.
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW IS THE WRONG APPROACH.
YOU KNOW INLAND EMPIRE HAS GROWN
OVER THE PAST YEARS TO BECOME
THE LOGISTICS HUBS FOR THE STATE
IN THE NATION.
HOWEVER YOU KNOW IF WE WANT TO
GROW BEYOND THAT WILL GO AB
ECONOMY THAT THOSE ON THE OTHER
THAN THAT.
WE NEED MORE DIRECT FOREIGN
INVESTMENT -- YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER OF SMALL BUSINESSES
EXPORTS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
LIKE COMBUSTION ASSOCIATES
INCORPORATED THE DEVELOP.
AND MANUFACTURE POWER GENERATION
SYSTEMS AND OTHERS WHO NEED THE
SUPPORT THE STATE WHEN BATTLING
WITH OTHER STATE BUSINESS FROM
OTHER STATES OR OTHER COUNTRIES.
ARM THE PROPOSED THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU TODAY I THINK HAS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
FEATURE WHICH IS A HAS TANGIBLE
AND VERIFIABLE GOALS OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS THAT WILL ALLOW
THE LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE HAS
IT BEEN AFFECTED.
AND REALLY ADDRESSES SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS THAT HAVE EXISTED
WITH PAST EFFORTS.
YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT THIS IS
GOING TO PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES FOR BUSINESSES IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND PAT PHONE
KUSHIDA PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE.
I'VE BEEN DOING INTERNATIONAL
TRADE WORK FOR THE LAST. TWENTY
YEARS ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER AND
WE ACTUALLY HOLD THE EXPORT
CENTER -- LICENSE FOR THEM
MINORITY BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY FOR THE US DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE.
WE HAVE TO DO A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO ASIA EXPORTS AND
IT'S EVEN HARDER THAN THAT WE
ALSO HAVE.
TO IN ORDER TO COUNTLESS
TRANSACTIONS.
THEY HAVE TO BE MINORITY OWNED
FARMS.
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE THE BARRIERS
WHEN WE HAVE TO ACTUALLY.
DO FINANCIAL EXPERT TRANSACTIONS
OF A HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION IN
THOSE FIRMS HAVE TO THE MINORITY
OWNED FIRMS.
I WILL TELL YOU.
THAT THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
DIFFICULT WORK AND THAT WE HAVE
RELIED HEAVILY ON THE FEW
RESOURCES AT THE STATE HAS IN
THE OFFICE AGO BEST TO HELP US.
DELIVER THAT TYPE OF SERVICE TO
OUR CONSTITUENCY THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT WORK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER AND I THINK THAT THE ASK.
THAT -- THE OFFICE IS MAKING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING.
IS FAIR I THINK IT THAT IT'S
NEEDED I THINK THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO PUT SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO
THIS BECAUSE THIS IS A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AFRAID NO OR REPRESENTING THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE WANT TO ASSOCIATE -- THE
SUPPORT WITH THOSE AT A PARTY
SPOKEN IN THOSE TO FOLLOW THIS
IS A VERY TIMELY PROPOSAL GIVEN
THE INTERNATIONAL FREIGHT
SITUATION WE WINTER TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANDREW ANTS
WE WOULD SHOW YOUR GRANTS WE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE PORT
OF LOS ANGELES.
THE FOREIGN.
DON'T ALWAYS STAY OPEN
PERPETUALLY.
AND IT TAKES CARRION FEEDING IT
TAKES ATTENTION TO SUSTAIN THEM
AND ALSO TO RESPOND TO THE
CHANGES -- ON INERTIA
INTERNATIONAL SCALES FORCE FLOW
OF CARGO CALIFORNIA'S A BIGGER
DESTINATION BUT IT'S ALSO.
A PLACE THAT WERE EXPORTS
ESPECIALLY FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO MARKETS ALL AROUND THE
WORLD.
THE PORCH LOCALLY INVEST AND
HAVING THE FOREIGN OFFICES AND
WE THINK IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE
FOR THE STATE TO DO THE SAME.
FOR SO THE F. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
YOU MAY HEAR ON BEHALF OF THE
MILKEN INSTITUTE WHICH IS A NON
PARTISAN NON PROFIT THINK TANK --
WE SUPPORT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU TODAY I'M FIVE DAYS
AGO WE RELEASED A REPORT
ENTITLED REBUILDING CALIFORNIA'S
TRADE POLICY INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND IN THAT REPORT -- OUR
RESEARCH HAD HIGHLIGHTED THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA IT LACKS AN
EFFECTIVE TRADE PROGRAM GLOBAL
FOOT PRINT COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES.
I'M ONE OF THE TOP
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HAVE IS
TO AUGMENT STAFF -- BUT
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN STATE CUTS IN THE PAST
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES HAVE AND
GROUPS HAVE TRIED TO STEP IN AND
FILL IN THE GAP BUT WE STILL
BELIEVE THAT.
THIS IS BEST MANAGED AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL I'M WHICH IS WHY
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT -- ADDING
AUGMENTING THE STAFF FOR THIS
THANK YOU.
GET AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE CORNELIUS BURKE
WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE OPERATE
FOR OFFICES IN CHINA I WOULD
WORK WITH GO THIS IS TWENTY
THIRTEEN ON TRADE BETWEEN THE
BAY AREA IN CHINA.
TRADE IS GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA
TRADE IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
MAINTAIN OUR ECONOMIC MIGHT
INCREASE JOBS BUT WE ARE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE COVERS PULLED.
THANK YOU WE'RE HERE WITH THEIR
TESTIMONY OR IN ALL THIS ITEM
OPEN.
IF YOU WANT WHICH NUMBER.
THIRTEEN OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE.
CENTRAL VALLEY IN GRANT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
ANOTHER ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES IS
ABOUT WHOSE MONEY IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU CHAIR.
I AND COMMITTEE I AM DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE TO HAVE MY NAME IS IS
ABOUT BECAUSE YES BECAUSE MINE.
ARE PROPOSAL FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IS FOR THE
EXPANSION OF STAFFING WITH THREE
NEW POSITIONS FOR THE OFFICE OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE. TO
BETTER FULFILL THE MISSION TO
SERVE SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THREE POINT
NINE MILLION STRONG WITH THE
NEEDED INFORMATION AND RESOURCES
SERVICE AN ADVOCATE ON THEIR
BEHALF AND STATE GOVERNMENTS.
ADMINISTER THE GRANTS PROGRAMS
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CONSULT WITH EXPERTS.
OUR OFFICE ALSO ASSIST WITH
SMALL BUSINESS DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS AND ECONOMIC
RECOVERY POST DISASTER.
OUR PROPOSAL IS FOR THOSE THREE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TO FOR THE
SUPPORT THE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
WE WELCOME YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FINANCE NOTHING.
L. L..
WE HAVE NO OF WE'RE NOT RAISING
ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS ISSUE.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
GIVEN ALL THIS ITEM OPEN.
OUR NEXT ITEM IS AT LATIMES YOU
NEVER.
FOURTEEN GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
ECONOMIC IMPACT TO THE BILLING
WHICH MISTER CHAIR THE TRIP
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL IN FRONT
OF YOU IS A NAME CHANGE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ALL
SENATE'S GOBIZ TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF ECONOMIC IMPACT
.
THAT TO BE ABBREVIATED -- E. I
WE'VE NOTED THAT THERE'S A
REDUNDANCY OF THE TERM BUSINESS
AND STATE AGENCIES THAT HAS LED
TO SOME CONFUSION FROM
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
OUTSIDE STATE GOVERNMENT SEEKING
OUR SERVICES.
AT THE TWO AGENCIES BEING GOBIZ --
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND ALSO THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY BE A C. S. TO
ACHIEVE.
ECONOMIC GROWTH SUCH AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATIONS.
FEW DEPARTMENTS UTILIZED
ACRONYMS AND OPT TO USE
ABBREVIATIONS THAT.
PARTICULAR AGENCIES THE GOBIZ
WORKS CLOSELY WITH SUCH AS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH ALSO KNOWN AS A PR.
THE NEW NAME AN ACRONYM REFLECT
THE COMPREHENSIVE DATA DRIVEN
APPROACH.
NEEDED FOR SUSTAINABLE INCLUSIVE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
I WILL.
HOW MUCH WILL IT COST THE STATE
TO REBRAND AND OTHER RESOURCES
BETTER INVESTED IN PROVING THE
CURRENT WEBSITE VERSES
REBRANDING?
WE ANTICIPATE THE MOST THE COST
WATCHING ABSORB ALL IN IT WITH
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION COMING
AND WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE
TO REFRESH A LOT OF THESE ASSETS
IN MATERIALS ANYWAY -- SO
THEREFORE -- ANY OF THE COSTS
SUCH AS WEBSITE CHANGES OR
CHANGES TO A LOGO ARE PROBABLY
GONNA NEED THAT CHANGE ANYWAY SO
THESE COSTS WE ANTICIPATE WILL
BE OBSERVABLE IN THE CURRENT.
BUDGET.
WHAT'S BETTER -- HOW YA REGION
EDUCATE ALL CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES ABOUT THIS CHANGE?
WELL THE NEW MINISTRATIONS
ALREADY MADE IT A PRIORITY FOR
PUBLIC INPUT AND STAKEHOLDER OUT
REACH.
SO THIS IS ALREADY BEING
ACCOMPLISHED A LOT OF THE
REGIONAL PARTNERS THAT WE'VE
BEEN MEETING WITH -- IN
INTERNATIONAL IN SMALL BUSINESS
AS YOU'VE HEARD -- BUT WE'RE
ALSO REACHING OUT TO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN CHAMBERS ACROSS
THE STATE -- AND STARTING MORE
REGULAR CONVENING SO THESE
GROUPS SO.
ON TOP OF THE OVER TEN THOUSAND
EMAIL LIST OF ALL OF OUR FORMER
INTERESTED PARTIES THAT HAVE
INTERACT WITH OUR OFFICE WE ALSO
HAVE.
A MORE REGULAR OUTRAGE THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
THE CHARGERS OFFICE HAS THAT SEE
BIG PROGRAMMER YES THE PULL THAT
OVER.
IN THE YEAR AND THE YEAR
[inaudible]
CONTROL ALSO.
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE BIG.
IT DOES ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ALSO IT'S A RESOURCE.
SO SIMILAR FUNCTION.
WHAT WHAT IS THE FULL -- I'M
SORRY WHAT IS THE FULL A BAD
NAME OF THE PROGRAM.
SEE BIG -- CBG.
WE'LL TELL YOU WHAT THE ACRONYM
STANDS.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND
SAYS GATEWAY.
I I BELIEVE THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
PRELIMINARY DISCUSSIONS ABOUT A
TRANSFER BUT THERE'S BEEN
NOTHING DECIDED.
OKAY I'M OPEN TO PUBLIC COMMENT
NEW SPEAKER ASYLUM.
BECAUSE YOU GUYS LOOKING TO SEE
BIG AND AND MISSION IS NOT TO
BECAUSE MR SAYS YOU CAN POSSIBLY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT TO DO SO WE
APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY WE'RE THE WHOLE SADDAM OPEN
SUB RESISTANT OF OUR HEARING.
OF THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
WE HAVEN'T AND CHECK ME OUT